This episode is gifted to you with limited commercial interruption by Macy's. Yes, and we have partnered with Macy's this holiday season to create our very own Macy's Gift Guide. Our Macy's Gift Guide has curated all things holiday to help you prepare for the season ahead with gift suggestions for every person on your list. So be sure to check it out. We're really proud of it. You can find a link in our Office Ladies Pod Instagram bio. And now on with the show. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey.
这一集由梅西百货为您倾情呈现，节目中包含少量商业广告。是的，在这个节日季，我们与梅西百货合作打造了专属于我们自己的梅西百货节日送礼指南。我们的梅西百货节日送礼指南精选了各种节日好物，为你备战接下来的节日季出谋划策，上面有为你名单上的每个人的送礼建议。所以一定要去看看。我们为此感到非常自豪。你可以在我们的 Office Ladies Pod Instagram 简介中找到链接。闲话少说，节目开始。我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。
We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Lovers Podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews, behind the scenes details, and lots of VFF stories. We're the Office Ladies 6.0.
我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。我们是好朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极办公室爱好者播客。每周，我们将通过独家采访、幕后细节以及大量 VFF（办公室好闺蜜）的故事，深入探索《办公室》的世界。我们是 Office Ladies 6.0 版。
Hello! Ho, ho, ho! Oh, I'm so excited for today. Everybody is dressed in their most festive outfits. Jenna has on the cutest hoodie ever. You guys, it looks homemade, Jenna. It's like... It is! It's so cute. It's got little mittens and a snowman. Where'd you get it? My mom gave this to me. She got it at a craft fair in St. Louis. Oh, I love a craft fair. And Sam has on the cutest Christmas sweatshirt. Sam, describe it. It is a light up Simpson's
大家好！霍，霍，霍！哦，我太期待今天了。每个人都穿着他们最喜爱的节日盛装。珍娜穿着有史以来最可爱的连帽衫。天哪，看起来像是自己做的，珍娜。就像是……确实是！太可爱了。上面有小连指手套和一个雪人。你在哪买的？我妈妈送给我的。她在圣路易斯的一个手工艺品展上买的。哦，我太喜欢手工艺品展了。萨姆穿着最可爱的圣诞运动衫。萨姆，描述一下。是一件发光的辛普森一家
the cutest Christmas sweatshirt. Sam, describe it. It is a light up Simpsons hoodie. Lights up. And then Cassie, you might win the prize of the day. I have a gingerbread onesie on that literally got delivered this morning. It's so cute. Just in time.
最可爱的圣诞运动衫。萨姆，描述一下。是一件发光的辛普森一家连帽衫。会发光。然后是卡茜，你可能会赢得今天的最佳着装奖。我穿着一件姜饼人连体衣，今天早上刚送达。太可爱了。来的真是时候。
Angela, you've got on your Santa hat and your red and white stripes like a candy cane. I love it. And do you wanna tell people what we're doing today? Cause we don't usually pop into your feet on a Friday. We don't, but we're feeling festive. And today we have a very fun bonus episode for you. Guess what the theme is.
安吉拉，你戴着圣诞老人帽，还穿着像拐杖糖一样的红白条纹衣服。我太喜欢了。你想告诉大家我们今天要干什么吗？因为我们平时不会在周五突然闯入你们的播客动态。我们确实不常这样，但我们今天感觉很有节日气氛。今天我们要为大家带来一期非常有趣的彩蛋节目。猜猜主题是什么。
Wait, I'm going to give you a hint everyone. As if our outfits didn't clue you in. What does this get you in the mood for everyone? Little baby, parumpa pum pum. Pum pum pum pum pum pum pum pum pum pum pum. I am a poor boy too, parumpa pum pum. Pum pum pum pum pum pum pum pum pum. I have no gift to bring, parumpa pum pum.
等等，我要给大家一个小提示。虽然我们的穿着已经暗示得很明显了。这能勾起大家对什么的渴望呢？小鼓手，哒啷帕隆帕品品。品品品品品品品品品品品。我也是个穷孩子，哒啷帕隆帕品品。品品品品品品品品品品。我没有什么礼物可以送，哒啷帕隆帕品品。
Pum pum pum pum pum pum pum pum pum. That's fit to give our king parr-a-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa- Well, we won't make you listen to me sing off-key much longer, but you guys, guess what this means? That's right! Get ready for a special holiday episode thanks to the folks at Macy's! Yes, thank you Macy's! You know, Angela, when we were preparing this episode, I went back and I watched that scene of you singing. I didn't know you were going to play it today, but my favorite thing about that is how at the end of that The camera pushes in on Michael and he's inviting someone We don't know yet who to go to Sandals with him and the look on his face when you know
品品品品品品品品品品。配不上我们的国王，帕——好吧，我不会让你听我跑调太久的，但你们知道这意味着什么吗？没错！准备好收看由梅西百货赞助的特别节日节目吧！是的，谢谢梅西百货！安吉拉，你知道吗，在我们筹备这一集的时候，我回头看了一下你唱歌的那场戏。我不知道你主要会在今天播放它，但我最喜欢那一点的是，在结尾时，镜头推向迈克尔，他正在邀请某个人——我们还不知道是谁——和他一起去桑德斯度假村，当你知道那一刻他的表情——
The person on the other line said yes, and of course, we're gonna find out it's jam. Yeah Oh his reaction talk about that little kid getting the best gift ever. Yes He's like well, it's all inclusive. Well, everyone, we have a really fun episode for you today. Brian Baumgartner stopped by to talk about Christmas on the Office, plus a fun holiday project of his. Then we have a festive Office Ladies gift exchange. I did a deep dive on the year Mariah Carey's Christmas song was dethroned from the number one spot.
另一端的人说“好”，当然，我们后来发现那是简。噢，他的反应，简直就像一个得到史上最好礼物的纯真小孩。是的。他就像是，嗯，这是全包的。好吧，各位，我们今天为大家准备了一期非常有趣的节目。布赖恩·鲍姆加特纳将做客节目，聊聊《办公室》里的圣诞节，以及他自己的一个有趣的节日项目。接着，我们将举行一场热闹的 Office Ladies 礼物交换活动。我还对玛丽亚·凯莉的圣诞歌曲被拉下榜首那一年的情况进行了深入研究。
Ooh. And Angela met a real life Santa's helper. Jenna, did you just do a summary? Oh my God. You did a summary, you can't help it. Yes, I think I did, but I will not do fast facts. Okay, we'll see. Not gonna do it.
噢。安吉拉还遇到了一位现实生活中的圣诞老人助手。珍娜，你刚才是不是做了一个总结？哦，天哪。你做了总结，你真是忍不住。是的，我想我是做了，但我不会做速报。好吧，我们走着瞧。才不做呢。
Okay. Before we get into today's episode, I am really curious, you guys. I love holiday traditions. I love hearing what other people's holiday traditions are. And Jenna, Sam, Cassie, I thought it'd be really fun for us to share something we do with our friends or family every year to celebrate the holidays. Sam, you want to go first? Sure. I go back to Milwaukee, Wisconsin and my brother and I go get a fresh cut Christmas
好吧。在我们进入今天的节目之前，我真的很好奇，大家。我非常喜欢节日传统。我喜欢听听其他人的节日传统是什么。珍娜、萨姆、卡茜，我觉得我们分享一下每年与朋友或家人一起庆祝节日做的事情，一定会非常有趣。萨姆，你想先来吗？好的。我回到了威斯康星州密尔沃基，我和我哥哥去为他的家人挑选一棵新砍的圣诞
tree for his family. And there's two dogs at the Christmas tree lot that we always look forward to seeing that are there every year. Oh my gosh! I love that! I can just picture all of that. All right, Cassie? The reason why I got the gingerbread onesie is my friends every year we do this thing called Rain Beer Games which is beer pong and we do it in the middle of the night and all dress up and this year my partner and I are gonna be ginger gingerbread men so we're gonna wear red wigs with our
树。圣诞树卖场里有两只狗，我们每年都很期待能见到它们。哦，天哪！我太喜欢了！我脑海里已经浮现出那个画面了。好吧，卡茜？我穿这件姜饼人连体衣的原因是，我的朋友们每年都会举办一个叫“雨啤酒游戏”的活动，其实就是啤酒乒乓球，我们会在半夜玩，大家都会精心打扮，今年我和我的搭档要扮演姜饼人，所以我们会在连体衣
onesies. Oh so cute. Well one of my favorite holiday traditions is holiday baking, Ange. And we always make my great-grandmother's snowball cookies. They're kind of like a Hungarian wedding cookie, but we always made them at the holidays. She made them. My grandma made them. My mom made them.
外面戴上红色的假发。哦，太可爱了。嗯，我最喜欢的节日传统之一就是节日烘焙，安吉。我们总是做我曾祖母的雪球饼干。它们有点像匈牙利婚礼饼干，但我们总是在节日里做。她做过。我奶奶做过。我妈妈做过。
Now I make them. And it was really sweet because this year, my daughter did a little cookbook at her school, and she put our recipe for the snowball cookies in their school cookbook. How special. But I can't wait to bake a big batch of those. Oh, I love that. Well that's kind of similar to mine.
现在我来做。非常温馨的是，今年我女儿在学校做了一本小食谱，她把我们的雪球饼干食谱放进了学校的食谱里。多有意义啊。但我已经迫不及待地想烤上一大盘了。哦，我太喜欢了。这和我有点像。
One of the things that Josh does is he gets up early before everyone else on Christmas morning and he goes downstairs and he makes coffee cake. Oh yeah. Yeah and then when the kids wake up we make them all wait at the top of the stairs and we have pictures from every year, Jenna, when they were little and now they're teenagers and they still want to do it. They wait at the top of the stairs and they're like Christmas cozy pajamas until we yell, all right come down! And then they run down the stairs to see all the gifts under the tree, because we always leave one from Santa
乔什的习惯之一是，在圣诞早晨每个人醒来之前，他会早早起床，下楼去制作咖啡蛋糕。哦，是的。是的，然后当孩子们醒来时，我们会让他们在楼梯口等着，我们每年都有照片，珍娜，从他们很小的时候到现在他们成了青少年，他们仍然想这么做。他们等在楼梯顶上，穿着舒适的圣诞睡衣，直到我们大喊：“好了，下来吧！”然后他们顺着楼梯跑下去，看树下的所有礼物，因为我们总是留下一份圣诞老人的
still, and the whole house smells like coffee cake, and I just love it. I love the smells of Christmas, of the Christmas baking and all of that. I know exactly what you're talking about. Yeah, so cozy. Okay, well I just love that you're talking about. Yeah, so cozy. Okay, well I just love that, thank you guys. Well we've shared before that the holidays
礼物，整个房子都弥漫着咖啡蛋糕的香味，我太喜欢这种感觉了。我太喜欢圣诞节的味道了，圣诞烘焙的香味等等。我完全知道你在说什麽。是的，太惬意了。好吧，我只是很喜欢你们谈论这个。是的，太惬意了。好吧，我只是很喜欢这个，谢谢你们。嗯，我们之前分享过，假期
were a very special time on the set of The Office, and our good friend Brian Baumgartner stopped by the Office Lady Studio to talk a little bit about his favorite Office Christmas memories. It was so good to see him. Yes, and he's also gonna talk about his new book that he co-wrote with Ben Silverman. It's already a to see him. Yes, and he's also going to talk about his new book that he co-wrote with Ben Silverman. It's already a New York Times bestseller. It's called Twas the Night
是《办公室》片场一个非常特殊的时期，我们的好朋友布赖恩·鲍姆加特纳做客 Office Ladies 工作室，跟我们聊了聊他最难忘的《办公室》圣诞回忆。见到他太棒了。是的，他还要聊聊他和本·西尔弗曼合著的新书。这已经是《纽约时报》畅销书了。书名叫《敦威扶林的圣诞前夜》。
Before Christmas at Dundermifflin. Yes, everyone, it is that traditional night before Christmas story, but with all of the characters from The Office. All right, well here is our chat with Brian. Brian Baumgartner, welcome to Office Ladies. Hi guys, it's so good to see you. What's up fella? Oh, you know, it's the most wonderful time of the year. Yep, it's time and I'm so happy to be here in your new spot here in my old stomping ground in Hollywood, California, which is weird
是的，各位，这就是那个传统的圣诞前夜故事，但主角换成了《办公室》里的所有角色。好了，接下来是我们与布赖恩的聊天。布赖恩·鲍姆加特纳，欢迎来到 Office Ladies。嗨，伙计们，见到你们太好了。最近怎么样，老兄？哦，你知道的，这是一年中最美好的时光。没错，时候到了，我很高兴能来到你们位于加利福尼亚州好莱坞我曾经的老地盘上的新工作室，这挺奇怪的
because neither of you live here, but thank you for supporting Hollywood. Your old memories? Yeah, I guess, yeah. I lived in West Hollywood when I first moved to California for many years. So did I, in fact we found out we were just a few blocks apart and we didn't even know.
因为你们俩都不住在这里，但谢谢你们支持好莱坞。你以前的回忆？对，我猜是吧。我刚搬到加州时，在西好莱坞住了很多年。我也是，事实上我们发现我们只隔了几个街区，甚至都不知道。
Oh, I knew Angela's spot. You didn't invite me over then. Oh, this was before I knew you? This was before I was on the office. I lived at Genesee in Santa Monica. And I lived on Stanley. Wow, that's very exciting. Well, Brian, thank you for joining us today
哦，我知道安吉拉的地方。那你当时没邀请我去。哦，这是在我认识你之前？这是在我加入《办公室》之前。我住在圣莫尼卡的杰尼斯街。我住在斯坦利街。哇，太令人兴奋了。布赖恩，谢谢你今天
on our special bonus holiday episode. This is my first time on Office Ladies in Person. Yep, that's right. You've been so wonderful and so supportive of our podcast. We have texted you the most random questions. Now, I don't know about, let's address that first off. Our texting. Well, I didn't, I meant to apologize before. Let's just say there was a contentious text exchange that was happening one week ago when I was literally in Scranton, Pennsylvania, sitting at dinner and I did get an office ladies text.
参加我们的节日特别彩蛋节目。这是我第一次亲临 Office Ladies。没错，就是这样。你一直对我们的播客给予极大的支持和帮助。我们经常给你发一些奇奇怪怪的问题。现在，我不知道，我们先来谈谈这个吧。我们发短信的事。嗯，其实我本来想先道个歉的。这么说吧，一周前，当我实际上在宾夕法尼亚州斯克兰顿吃晚餐时，发生了一场激烈的短信交流，我确实收到了 Office Ladies 的短信。
Now- You did. It was about the accountant's webisodes. Yes. I wasn't gonna reveal what it was about, but let's just say- We shared about it. Oh, it was conflicting.
现在——你收到了。是关于会计师网络短剧的。是的。我本来不想透露是什么内容的，但可以说——我们分享过了。哦，充满争议。
Oh boy. Well, not really. Now you're gonna make enemies. Not really boy. Well, not really. Now you're going to make enemies. Not really, not really, not really. And something was said, I got really fired up. And that was what I was going to say to you when I saw you today was like, that was kind of old school Brian, like fired up texting as fast as I could.
哦天哪。其实也没有。现在你要树敌了。其实也没有，天哪。其实也没有。现在你要树敌了。其实没有，其实没有，其实没有。然后有人说了一些话，我一下子就火大了。我今天见到你时本来想对你说的是，那有点像老派的布赖恩，就像火力全开、以最快速度打字回复一样。
Uh-huh. Like, I have to go right now, but this is aggravating me. My favorite thing when I can tell you're fired up is you do the one word. You'll say, not true. Correct. False. Yeah. You kind of become Dwight. There was, yeah.
嗯哼。就像是，我得马上走，但这把我惹毛了。当我能看出你火大了时，我最喜欢看你只回一个词。你会说，并非如此。正确。假的。对。你有点变成德怀特了。确实，是的。
We won't reveal what it was that had us all fired up. Yes. That's for Office Ladies, Burn It to the Ground. Okay. That's our next podcast in another like five years. In five years, Burn It to the Ground. Okay. That's our next podcast in another like five years. In five years, Burn It to the Ground. That's right. Well, maybe you'll have me back on then.
我们不会透露是什么让我们这么火大。是的。那是留给《办公室女士：彻底烧毁》的节目。好吧。那是我们大约五年后的下一个播客。五年后，《彻底烧毁》。好吧。那是我们大约五年后的下一个播客。五年后，《彻底烧毁》。没错。也许到那时你会邀请我回来。
We can't wait. And then we'll burn it to the ground. Together. All right, perfect. I can't wait for you to be like untrue. But for today's episode, Brian, we wanna reminisce about the office holiday episodes. They were so great. What was your favorite? Do you have ace about the office holiday episodes? They were so great.
我们迫不及待。然后我们把它彻底烧毁。一起。好的，太完美了。我等不及你像那样说“不对”了。但对于今天的节目，布赖恩，我们想回顾一下《办公室》的圣诞特辑。它们太棒了。你最喜欢哪一集？你对《办公室》的圣诞特辑有什么看法？它们太棒了。
What was your favorite? Do you have a favorite onset memory, a favorite offset memory? Well, so I don't think that I have rapsidized with you guys probably because it was on Zoom and not in person. I think that's a word. That's a fancy word.
你最喜欢哪一集？你有什么片场的美好回忆，或者片场之外的美好回忆吗？嗯，所以我想我可能没有和你们俩滔滔不绝地聊过这个，因为当时是在 Zoom 上而不是面对面。我觉得那是个词。那是个高级词汇。
So fancy. Rapsidized. For me, when people ask, cause people ask all the time, like what's your favorite episode or whatever, I think it's for me, it's about what was going on outside of it now as much as what the actual episode was, right? Same. Same.
太高级了。滔滔不绝。对我来说，当人们问起时——因为人们总是问，比如你最喜欢哪一集之类的——我认为对我来说，这不仅关乎实际的那一集是什么，更关乎当时戏外发生了什么，对吧？一样。一样。
So for example, for me, I don't know if it's the same, we haven't discussed this, this is not pre-planned. Like for me, if people say know if it's the same, we haven't discussed this, this is not pre-planned. Like for me, if people say like, what's your favorite episode? At this point, I pretty much say stress relief. And the reason why is one, great episode times two, double parter, but for me, I was, am still a big sports fan.
所以举个例子，对我来说，我不知道是不是一样，我们之前没有讨论过这个，这不是事先安排好的。就像对我来说，如果人们问，比如你最喜欢哪一集？此时此刻，我基本上会说是《压力缓解》。原因在于：第一，这是一集精彩的剧集，而且是两部分连播；但对我来说，我当时是、现在依然是一个超级体育迷。
And that episode, as I'm sure you guys know, aired after the Super Bowl that year. And that was the first, I was invited by NBC to go to the Super Bowl. And that was the first time I had ever been at a Super Bowl. And so I'm in the Super Bowl, which, you know, is the Super Bowl.
那一集，我敢肯定你们也知道，是那年超级碗之后播出的。那是 NBC 邀请我去超级碗的第一次。那是我第一次去超级碗现场。所以我在超级碗现场，你知道，那是超级碗。
It's the Super Bowl. And on the like... Jumbotron. Jumbotron. I think that's an old timey word, I don't think they call it that anymore. You know what, I'm gonna rhapsodize about it a little bit and then I'll get back to you. That just means thinking.
那是超级碗。而在那个……大屏幕上。大屏幕。我觉得那是个老派的词，现在大家不这么叫了。你知道吗，我要滔滔不绝地讲一会儿，然后再回到正题。那只是说明在思考。
There was like the office after the Super Bowl and it was like, that's our show, like that was it. So that for me has a particular, well, it's obviously fond memories of that. I think for the Christmas episode, it's the same but different. Like it's about what was happening outside and as I'm sure you guys have or will talk about,
当时就像是超级碗之后的办公室特辑，就像是，那是我们的节目，就是这样。所以对我来说，这有着特殊的、显然美好的回忆。我认为对于圣诞特辑，也是大同小异。就像是关于外面发生了什么，正如我敢肯定你们已经或将要谈到的那样，
like that very first Christmas episode, it didn't launch the show. It wasn't the first episode of the show, but that episode really launched the success of the show. Like that episode became our largest audience since the premiere. And from there, you know, then Steve wins the Golden Globe
就像那第一个圣诞特辑，它并没有开创这部剧。它不是这部剧的第一集，但那一集真正奠定了这部剧的成功。那一集成了我们自首播以来收视率最高的一集。从那以后，你知道，史蒂夫在三四周后就赢得了金球奖，一切都开始发生了。我们进入了——对，我们转折了。你知道，当时我们甚至没有拿到这一整季的续订合同。而从那之后就开始了。很明显我们将继续播出一段时间。
like three or four weeks later, everything starts happening. We get into the- Yeah, we turned a corner. You know, at that point, we didn't even have a full order for the season. And they started after that. It became clear we were gonna be around for a while.
所以，另一件我经常提到的是——这已经是很久以前的事了——我谈到那一集很特别，因为每个人都在里面做了点什么。每个人都在某种程度上得到了展示。然后我说，你可以争辩说，除了梅雷迪思，然而她在剧集快结束时还是迎来了她或许是剧中最棒的时刻之一
So, and the other thing I always, and this was a long time ago, I talked about like that episode being special because everybody did something. Like there was, everyone was sort of featured in some way. And then I said, you can make an argument, except Meredith, however, she ends up having maybe one of the greatest moments on the show ever
当时她脱掉了上衣，而迈克尔在剧集快结束时抓拍了照片。所以，就像是在最后，她也某种程度上爆发了。这让那一集变得很特别。拍它们也很难。那是她说的。拍它们很难。
when she takes her top off and Michael snaps the picture over at the very end of the episode. So that like, suddenly like at the end, she sort of explodes as well. So that made it special. They were also hard. That's what she said. They were hard.
你算一个。我算一个？对。圣诞特辑很难制作，因为有很多大型的派对群戏，所有人都参与其中。每个人都在表演，是的。我觉得这些是最快乐的集数，因为我们真的要在这些
You get one. I get one? Yeah. They were hard to produce the Christmas episodes because big party group scenes, everybody involved. Everyone playing, yeah. I feel like those were some of the most joyous episodes because we really would be in these
类似集体派对的场景中待上大半集，然后当然我们还要拍各种桥段。我确信我们很难管束。我们可能就像在一间满是六岁小孩的屋子里拍电视剧一样，对吧，做着各种搞笑桥段。但我只记得，布赖恩，我记得你坐在史蒂夫的膝盖上假扮圣诞老人，我知道每个人都会不断跟你提起这件事，但这就像是，没有人能忍住不笑。
Like group party situations for most of the episode and then of course we would be doing bits And I'm sure we were very hard to wrangle We probably like trying to make a TV show with a room full of six Year olds or something right doing all our bits. But I just remember, Brian, I remember when you sit on Steve's lap as Santa, and I know everyone always brings it up to you, but it was like we, no one could get through it. Yeah, yeah, I mean that in terms of like singular moments
是的，是的，我是说就圣诞特辑中对我而言独特的时刻而言，确实如此。部分原因在于，你知道，当你回看童年的照片，在那个没有——你知道，我们当时没有每隔五秒钟就把一切都录下来。你回看这些照片或家庭录像之类的东西。这就成了你记忆的一部分。现在，我和史蒂夫坐在史蒂夫膝盖上的NG镜头在各个地方到处都是，所以它让这个记忆在我的脑海里永远新鲜。而我跟别人说过的一件事——我觉得这个麦克风效果会非常好——那就是这很有趣，你们也这么觉得，但我就坐在离他最近的头排座位上，
for me in the Christmas episodes, I mean that one does. And part of it is like, you know, when you look back at photos from your childhood back before there was, you know, we didn't have everything wasn't videotaped every five seconds. You look back at these photos or like video home, whatever. And that becomes like a part of your memory. Now that the blooper is real with me sitting on Steve's lap has just like everywhere so it's like keeps like it keeps that so fresh in my mind and the thing that i've said to people and i think this microphone will work really well that like it was funny and you guys but like i had the like literal front row seat to him
当我坐下来时，他发出的那个声音。他发出了那个声音，他知道自己戴着麦克风，但声音直接传到了我的耳朵里。每当我坐下时，他就会发出这样的声音。我简直……太难了。我根本演不下去，每个人都在笑，但我也在笑。我简直……太难了。我吃不消，每个人都在笑，但我也在笑。而且那种表情，他的脸痛苦万分，
and the noise that he made when I sat down. And he made it and he knew he had the mic but it was right in my ear. And as I would sit down, he did this. And I could, it was so difficult for me. I couldn't eat and everyone else is laughing but I was laughing too. I could, it was so difficult for me. I couldn't eat, and everyone else was laughing, but I was laughing too. And the way, his face was just so pained
几乎像是有汗水顺着他的脸颊流下来。我记得挺早的时候，我不知道，也许就在拍了一两次之后，我们可能拍了30次，我转向他问：“你没事吧？就像这样，你没事吧？”他回答说：“哦，天哪，没事，不，我完全没事。”
and almost he manufactured sweat coming down the side of his face. And I remember pretty early on, I don't know, maybe after just one or two takes, and we probably did 30, I turned to him and I'm like, are you okay? Like this is like, are you okay? And he was like, oh God, yeah, no, I'm totally fine.
我的意思是，你了解他，他就那种态度：“哦，不，我完全没事。我只是在装出这个样子而已，不过是的。”好吧，如果你看那一集，背景里的人都在笑场。哦，百分之百。明迪直接走开了。对。她直接转身就离开了。不，埃德直接跳到走廊后面去了。他跳到了走廊后面，是的。
I mean, you know him, he was just like, oh no, I'm totally fine. Like I'm just literally putting this on, but yeah. Well, if you watch that episode, people are breaking in the background. Oh, 100%. Mindy just walks out. Yeah. She just turns and leaves. No, Ed dives behind the hall. He d 100%. Mindy just walks out. Yeah.
太荒谬了。我们从来没有拍到过一次所有人都从头到尾忍住不笑、足以把这一段剪进正片里的镜头，最后他们只能放弃。是的。
She just turns and leaves. No, Ed dives behind the hall. He dives behind, into the hallway, yeah. It's so ridiculous. We never ever got a take where people held it together the whole time long enough to actually put the show together and they just gave up. Yeah.
他们心想，算了吧。算了吧。就是这样了。是的，你知道，我想对我来说发生这种情况的唯一另一次——这跟圣诞节无关，但我还是会讲出来——我记得对我来说发生这种情况的唯一另一次是和艾米·瑞安在一起。
They were like, forget it. Forget it. This is what it is. Yeah, you know, the only other time that I think that happened for me, this is not Christmas related, but I'll tell it, the only other time that I think that happened for me This is not Christmas related But I'll tell it the only other time that I remember happening for me was with Amy Ryan That was for me. That was my purse like that one was difficult the sitting at the At the vending machine buttons and the coin and the coins her earnest eyes looking into mine
那是针对我。那对我来说就像是——那个很难，坐在自动售货机的按钮、硬币前，硬币哗啦啦响，她那真挚的眼睛看着我的眼睛。我的意思是，她就那样直直地盯着你，然后说“这是一个按钮”，我简直无法——她真的是在真挚地试图告诉我——那一幕，如果你回去看的话，仍然是——我想那是最后一条，而且我认为要么是我做出的决定，要么是我们讨论过，我当时说：“伙计们，我不知道接下来会怎样。”我们知道它会被剪辑成那种“我绝对要和霍莉上床”的效果。
So I mean and she just aimed just stared right at you and her saying this is a button I could not like that she was really earnestly trying to tell me that that one if you go back and look still like the last take I think and I think there was a conscious decision either by me or we were discussing it I was was like, guys, I don't know how this is gonna go. And we knew that it was gonna edit into that, like, I'm totally gonna bang Holly thing. And so I was like, oh, I can smile, Kevin can smile. Because he thinks what's coming.
所以我当时想，哦，我可以笑，凯文可以笑。因为他知道接下来会发生什么。
Yeah, because he sees what's coming. But that one was, oh no, that was really difficult. And remember the episode Dwight's Christmas when my character's up on the credenza and I can't get down and it's in a montage and Kevin goes to help get me down. And you basically put me like when someone carries a football under their armpit.
是的，因为他看到了要发生的事情。但那一幕，哦不，真的很难。还记得《德怀特的圣诞节》那一集吗，我的角色挂在装饰柜上，我下不来，那是一个蒙太奇镜头，凯文过去帮忙把我弄下来。你基本上把我像别人把橄榄球夹在胳肢窝底下一样扛着。
Like in this weird football hold. And I was like, I almost went completely upside down and they just kept it in and I saw that the other day and I started cracking up because I knew it was just you messing with me. Yeah. Which we would do all the time. That happens. Well, Brian, I want to talk about something else with you.
就像这种奇怪的橄榄球抱法。我当时感觉自己快要完全倒挂过来了，他们居然把这剪进去了，前几天我看到那一幕时笑得前仰后合，因为我知道那只是你在捉弄我。对，那是我们经常做的事。这种事会发生。好吧，布赖恩，我想跟你聊点别的。
There's a reason why you've been using all these really big words today. It's because you are an author and you right now have a book called The Night Before Christmas at Dunder Mifflin. Yes, I know. Some people say, and you can't see it if you're listening to us, that you shouldn't judge a book by its cover. I think the cover looks really good. So good. I want to be judged by the cover. It looks so great. The illustrations are so cool, Brian. Will you talk to us a little bit about how this all came together?
你今天用了这么多高级词汇是有原因的。那是因为你是一位作家，你现在有一本名为《敦威扶林的圣诞前夜》的书。是的，我知道。有些人说——如果你在听我们的节目，你是看不见的——你不能以貌取人。我觉得这本书的封面看起来真的很棒。太棒了。我想让人以貌取人。它看起来太棒了。插图太酷了，布赖恩。你能跟我们聊聊这一切是怎么促成的吗？
Well, part of the idea came from what fans have talked to me, and I'm sure the two of you about, which is one of their family traditions at the holidays has been to binge watch the Office Christmas episodes. Yes. That's like part of their holiday tradition. That's become like a thing.
嗯，部分灵感来自于粉丝们跟我聊过的话题，我确信你们俩也听过，那就是他们家在节日期间的传统之一就是一口气刷完《办公室》的圣诞特辑。是的。这就像是他们节日传统的一部分。这已经成了一种风潮。
Like how we used to watch Rudolph. Yeah and Frosty and the Grinch. Elf, Elf, sure. Yes. The people are watching the Christmas episodes. So that's sort of where it started. The idea for adapting the Night Before Christmas poem. You know, The Night Before Christmas, the poem, the OG, not at Dunder Mifflin, that
就像我们以前看《鲁道夫》一样。是的，还有《雪人》和《怪物史莱克》。《精灵总动员》，《精灵总动员》，当然。是的。人们都在看圣诞特辑。所以这就是它的起因。改编《圣诞前夜》这首诗的想法。你知道，《圣诞前夜》这首诗，原版，不是敦威扶林版的，那
was truthfully the very first text I ever memorized. That was my first memorized performance in front of my family. How old were you? We had a giant, and no one can see my hands. Probably three feet tall, like a big illustrated version of The Night Before Christmas. And it started by me reading it when I learned to read.
其实是我背诵的第一首诗。那是我在家人面前背诵表演的第一个作品。你当时多大？我们有一个巨大的——没人能看到我的手——大概三英尺高，是一本带大插图的《圣诞前夜》。在我学会阅读后，我就是通过读它来开始阅读的。
What is that? Four, five, six-ish. You hold up the big giant book, Brian? I would be holding the book and would read the thing. And that was one of our traditions. How cute. And then one year I memorized it. And then I recited it for everybody
那是什麽？四個、五個、六個左右。你舉起那本巨大無比的書，佈萊恩？我會拿著這本書並讀裡面的內容。那是我們的傳統之一。多可愛啊。後來有一年我把它背下來了。然後我背給每個人聼
as my sister turned the pages and I didn't look at it. So that. That is so sweet. So that has a special connection to me. But in that book, one of the most important things is the illustrations. And so when we started to have this idea and talk about adapting The Night Before Christmas
我姐姐幫忙翻頁，而我沒看書。所以那。這真是太甜蜜了。所以這對我來說有著特別的聯繫。但在那本書中，最重要的事情之一就是插圖。因此，當我們開始有這個想法並談論改編《聖誕前夜》
and setting it here in the office, I had worked on this show, Trash Truck, that Glen Keane had executive produced. Now, Glen Keane is like literally a god in the animated world. So I called him, I called him about five times to say like, you have to, he's very busy. I was like, you have to do this,
併把它設定在辦公室裡時，我曾參與過格倫·基恩擔任執行製片的節目《垃圾車》。現在，格倫·基恩在動畫界簡直就是神一般的存在。所以我打電話給他，我打電話給他大約五次，說像，你必須，他非常忙。我當時想，你必須做這個，
because I knew he was a big fan of The Office. So I was like, look, you have to do this. Maiel Gormelin, he is the one who actually did the drawings, but I was on calls with Glenn, his whole team, and Maiel every week. That was my favorite part of this for, I don't know, two, three months. We would have like a two-hour call
因為我知道他是《辦公室瘋雲》的超級粉絲。所以我當時想，聽著，你必須這麽做。馬伊爾·戈爾梅林，他才是真正畫畫的人，但我每週都與格倫、他的整個團隊以及馬伊爾通電話。這是我最喜歡的部分，持續了，我不知道，兩、三個月。我們會進行大約兩個小時的通話
and talk about every image and what it looked like and how the characters were developed. And that was really fun to do. call and talk about every image and what it looked like and how the characters were developed. And that was really fun to do. When you open up the book, just the very first page, you know, it says to us the night before Christmas and all through Dunder Mifflin, not an accountant was stirring, not a mouse was a click in. It's so cool because it just brings you right into the world of the office. Pam is sleeping at her desk.
併討論每一張圖片、它看起來的樣子以及角色的開發過程。這真的很有趣。通話並討論每一張圖片、它看起來的樣子以及角色的開發過程。這真的很有趣。當你打開書，第一頁，你知道的，它對我們說聖誕前夜，鄧德米夫林上空，沒有一個會計師在活動，沒有一隻老鼠在點擊。太酷了，因为它直接把你帶入了辦公室的世界。帕姆在她的辦公桌前睡覺。
Jim's sleeping. Everybody's sleeping kind of at their desks. It looks like the Christmas party has happened and we've all sort of fallen asleep after the party. I'm so glad that you mentioned that because when the first drawings started coming in, the thing that I kept catching inside of me, I was like, where are we? Where exactly are we?
吉姆在睡覺。每個人都在他們的辦公桌前睡覺。看起來聖誕派對已經結束了，我們大家在派對後都睡著了。我很高興你提到這點，因為當第一批畫稿進來時，我一直在內心琢磨的一件事是，我們在哪裡？我們到底在哪裡？
Are we backed by the accountants? Like where? Right. And so that was my first major and only sort of note about that was the architecture of the space is so important. Like I wanna know where we are within this layout of the, that everybody knows so well. Most of the people who read this will understand it. So he took that and like flew with it and including exactly
我們在會計部門後面嗎？在哪裡？沒錯。所以這是我對此的第一個重大且唯一的意見，就是空間的建築結構太重要了。就像我想知道我們在這個佈局中的什麼位置，每個人都非常熟悉。大多數讀過這個的人都會理解它。所以他接受了這個並盡情發揮，包括完全
what you just brought up. Like we're coming into the book and so the angle, the perspective is us entering Dunder Mifflin. Yeah. From that classic like we see the Jim and Dwight clump and Michael's office and the painting on the wall and you know. There's so many things too like the details of that plant that was next to the lamp that we all ended up trying to plant in the finale and Pam's desk there's a little plant by her desk just all these things are so specific to the show. Yeah and it's just it's really fun Brian it's kind of like And it's just, it's really fun, Brian. It's kind of like, I got the Lego, the office Lego one year, and when you put it together and you see all the details,
你剛纔提到的。就像我們正在進入書中，所以角度、視角就是我們進入鄧德米夫林。是的。從那個經典的畫面，我們看到吉姆和德懷特的組合、邁克爾的辦公室以及牆上的畫，你知道的。還有很多事情，比如燈旁邊那株植物的細節，我們最後都試圖在結局中種植，帕姆的桌子旁邊有一株小植物，所有這些事情都非常符合這部劇的特色。是的，這真的很有趣，佈萊恩，這有點像，而且這真的很有趣，佈萊恩。這有點像，我有一年得到了樂高，辦公室樂高，當你把它拼好並看到所有的細節時，
I just think that your book is illustrated in that same fun way where you see all these little nods. Like Andy's wearing a hat that says I went to Cornell. Yes, well, that's his gift. I know. From Santa. From Santa. I have to say, Santa is a much better. I know. From Santa. From Santa.
我只是覺得你的書也是用同樣有趣的方式插圖的，你可以看到所有這些小彩蛋。比如安迪戴著一頂寫著我去了康奈爾的帽子。是的，嗯，那是他的禮物。我知道。從聖誕老人那裡。從聖誕老人那裡。我不得不說，聖誕老人是一個好得多。我知道。從聖誕老人那裡。從聖誕老人那裡。
I have to say Santa is a much better gift giver than Michael Scott. Michael Scott is. Yes. In this book he really knows his employees well. It's very sweet. I mean he gives Angela pills to heal her cat's infection. Yeah, well obviously. It's really fun.
我不得不說聖誕老人是一個比邁克爾·斯科特好得多的送禮者。邁克爾·斯科特是。是的。在這本書中，他真的很了解他的員工。非常溫馨。我的意思是，他給安吉拉藥來治療她貓的感染。是的，很明顯。這真的很有趣。
My cats are always ill. Now we should let our listeners know that this is a little PG-13. It's a little bit for your older kids. This is not for your five year old. Cause like the show, right? The book has nods to the show. So if the content of the show feels appropriate to watch with your children,
我的貓總是在生病。現在我們應該讓我們的聽眾知道這有點PG-13。它更適合大一點的孩子。這不適合五歲的孩子。就像這個節目一樣，對吧？這本書向節目致敬。所以如果節目的內容覺得適合和你的孩子一起看，
then the book is appropriate. Yeah, I would say that it would be like a middle of the road episode of The Office. So it's not like sexual harassment. Oh no, no, no, no, no, no. Scott's Todd, or Dinner Party. But that's what she said. Yes, there are some jokes.
那麼這本書是合適的。是的，我會說這就像《辦公室瘋雲》中規中矩的一集。所以這不像性騷擾。哦不，不，不，不，不，不。斯科特的托德，或是晚宴派對。但這就是她說的。是的，有些笑話。
It's funny because I just have been doing signings. Oh, I mean, you like little ones. Like make this out to Gabe for his first birthday party. And I sort of did a look like, hmm. Well, Gabe can read this book. Gabe doesn't know any better. He's one. It's gonna go right over Gabe's head.
這很有趣，因為我一直在做簽名活動。哦，我的意思是，你喜歡小傢伙。比如把這個寫給蓋比作爲他的第一個生日派對。我有點看了看，嗯。好吧，蓋比可以讀這本書。蓋比不懂。他一嵗。這會直接從蓋比頭頂飛過。
That's true. But yes, it is intended to be an Office fan keepsake. Yes. Not specifically. It's not a children's book. For a four year old. That's right. Exactly.
沒錯。但是是的，它旨在成爲《辦公室》粉絲的紀念品。是的。並不是專門的。這不是一本兒童書。給四嵗小孩看的。沒錯。完全正確。
Yes. I did want to say that I love the button at the end for a true Office fan. There is someone that Michael Scott Santa did not include. Yes. I won't ruin it. Well. It's perfect. I won't ruin it. Well. It's perfect.
是的。我確實想說我很喜歡給真正的辦公室粉絲的結尾。有一個人是邁克爾·斯科特聖誕老人沒有包括在內的。是的。我不會劇透的。嗯。這太完美了。我不會劇透的。嗯。這太完美了。
I think you can guess. I will tell you the rhyming and like having a legit rhyme is often not as easy as you think that it might be. And so I had constructed how I wanted it to end and there were words that was a specific word that was really difficult to rhyme with. And then, well. What was it? You'll have to read it.
我想你能猜到。我會告訴你押韻以及擁有一個合法的韻腳通常並不像你想像的那麼容易。所以我構建了我希望它如何結束的方式，有些詞是一個非常難押韻的特定詞。然後，嗯。那是什麼？你得自己去讀。它的結尾變成了，你得自己去讀。
The button became, you'll have to read it. Yeah, you'll have to read it. Okay. But that is, that. We won't reveal. It was, and I think it turned out better, particularly along with the illustration. But yes, it came out of an inability to rhyme a certain word.
結尾變成了，你得自己去讀。是的，你得自己去讀。好的。但就是這樣，那個。我們不會透露。那是，而且我認為結果更好，特別是配合插圖。但是是的，它是因爲無法給某個特定的詞押韻而產生的。
Well, I just think this is so fun. I think the Office fans are gonna love it. What a great part of a holiday tradition. Now they can watch their favorite Office holiday episode. They can read. Yes. The night before Christmas at Dunder Mifflin. Yes, again, it's not a,
嗯，我只是覺得這太有趣了。我認為《辦公室》的粉絲會喜歡它。這真是節日傳統的一個偉大部分。現在他們可以看他們最喜歡的《辦公室》節日劇集了。他們可以讀。是的。《鄧德米夫林的聖誕前夜》。是的，再說一次，這不是一個，
because some people have asked like, oh, which episode is it? Like, it's not a specific episode. There are nods to certainly iconic moments from characters throughout the show or specific character traits from characters throughout the show as well as all of the Office Christmas episodes.
因爲有些人問過，哦，這是哪一集？就像，這不是特定的一集。這裡有對整個節目中角色的標誌性時刻的致敬，或者是整個節目中角色的特定性格特點，以及所有《辦公室》的聖誕節劇集。
Which makes it perfect. Yes, it's for fans. It's for fans. Brian, thank you so much for coming by and talking with us Thank you so much. Happy holidays to all of you out there and to all a good night. No, I don't You have such a beautiful rich voice though, I would listen to you read the night before Christmas at the night before Christmas at Dunder Meslin. Hey, by the way, you can. Is there an audio version?
這讓它變得完美。是的，這是為粉絲準備的。這是為粉絲準備的。佈萊恩，非常感謝你來和我們聊天 非常感謝。祝你們大家節日快樂，祝大家有個美好的夜晚。不，我沒有 廙你的聲音真好聽，我會聽你讀鄧德米夫林的聖誕前夜在鄧德米夫林的聖誕前夜。嘿，順便說一句，你可以。有有聲版本嗎？
Oh yes, there is. There it is. Yes, there is. If you don't wanna read to your children who are old enough for this book, well, you can have me do it for you. Yay. I love it.
哦，有的，有的。這不就有了。是的，有的。如果你不想讀給已經長大到可以看這本書的孩子聽，嗯，你可以讓我替你讀。耶。我太喜歡了。
Thanks, Brian. All right, thanks guys. Thanks for having me. Love you, B. It was so fun having Brian in the studio with us. You know, Jenna, I was sitting there thinking, gosh, it's been a while since the three of us have all been in one room together.
謝謝你，佈萊恩。好的，謝謝你們。謝謝你們邀請我。愛你，B。很高興佈萊恩來到我們的工作室。你知道，珍娜，我坐在那裡想，天哪，我們三個人聚在同一個房間裡已經有一段時間了。
Yeah. In person. It's true. I mean, I talk to Brian all the time. I see Brian quite often, actually. And so do you, but the three of us, it's been a while. All together, yeah. And we'll be sure to put a link in our stories so you can get all the details about his new book.
是的。親自。是真的。我的意思是，我經常和佈萊恩說話。其實我經常見到佈萊恩。你也是，但我們三個人，已經有一段時間了。都在一起，是的。我們一定會在我們的動態中放一個鏈接，這樣你就可以了解關於他的新書的所有詳情。
It is so cute, and it would make a good gift if you have an office lover in your family. And Brian worked so hard on it. He really did. Well, speaking of great gifts, it's time for our office ladies gift exchange, thanks to Macy's. Woohoo, Sam, Cassie, get in here.
它太可愛了，如果你的家族裡有一個辦公室愛好者，這將是一個很好的禮物。佈萊恩為此付出了很多努力。他真的付出了。嗯，說到好禮物，感謝梅西百貨，是時候進行我們的辦公室女士禮物交換了。哇哦，薩姆，卡西，進來吧。
Here we go. Hi. Bear with go. Hi. Bear with us, guys. This is so fun, the four of us being in the room together. Yeah, this is nice. I actually really love this. We gotta do it more. Okay, so we have presents
我們開始吧。嗨。忍耐一下，夥計們。我們四個人共處一室真是太有趣了。是的，這很好。我其實真的很喜歡這個。我們得經常這樣做。好的，我們有禮物
and one of our very favorite holiday treats. It's time to give love, give Moose Munch. Everybody. Woohoo! Let me open it up. That's right, we're gonna snack. We're gonna open gifts. And we got all this stuff at Macy's,
这也是我们最喜欢的节日零食之一。是时候表达爱意了，送上 Moose Munch 爆米花。大家快来！呜呼！让我打开它。没错，我们要吃零食了。我们要拆礼物了。我们在梅西百货买到了所有这些东西，
including the Moose Munch. Here, I'm gonna put it in a big bowl so we can share. I brought it. Oh my gosh, I love Moose Munch. I'm like so excited about this. Oh my gosh, sorry. Is Moose Munch just assorted popcorn flavor? But it also, yeah, so there's like chocolatey popcorn,
包括 Moose Munch。来，我要把它倒进一个大碗里，这样我们就可以分享了。我带了这个。哦天哪，我太喜欢 Moose Munch 了。我对此兴奋得不得了。哦天哪，抱歉。Moose Munch 只是各种口味的爆米花吗？但它也，对，里面有巧克力味的爆米花，
there's caramely popcorn, and there's also nuts. It's just the sweet and salty paradise is what it is. Did I have one Tom? Yeah. Okay, now we have our snack. That's our party snack. This is great, thank you. I love this much. We get it every year.
还有焦糖味的爆米花，里面也有坚果。这就是一个甜味和咸味的天堂。我吃了一个吗，汤姆？吃了吧。好了，现在我们有零食了。这就是我们的派对零食。太棒了，谢谢。我太喜欢这个了。我们每年都买。
Alright, so we put your presents out there. Everybody gets two things. You get a big and a little. Should we start with the littles? Let's start with the littles. Oh Sam, yours are very similar in size. One of them is slightly smaller than the other. Okay. Sam, you go first.
好吧，我们把你们的礼物放在那儿了。每人两件。一个大的和一个小的。我们从小的开始吗？我们就从小的开始吧。哦，萨姆，你们俩的礼物尺寸非常接近。其中一个比另一个稍微小一点。好吧。萨姆，你先来。
Okay. I realize I put Cassie's in the identical gift bag, so I had to let her know which is hers. Which is hers. Okay. Opening, opening. Sam's going first. Okay.
好的。我意识到我把凯西的礼物放在了相同的礼品袋里，所以我得让她知道哪个是她的。哪个是她的。好的。拆，拆开。萨姆先来。好的。
All right. So Sam, I know this is a tradition of yours, and I hope you don't have this one. Oh, I have a feeling I know what this is. Do you? Oh, wow. OK. Oh, it has chopsticks, too? OK, describe it.
好吧。萨姆，我知道这是你的传统，我希望你没有这个。哦，我有一种预感，我知道这是什么。是吗？哦，哇。好吧。哦，它还有筷子？好吧，描述一下。
OK, so it is a glass Christmas ornament. I have a tradition on my tree of only food ornaments. Yes. Of are these buns? Are these like? They're like dumplings. Yes. That's the word I couldn't think of, dumplings.
好吧，这是一个玻璃圣诞树挂饰。我的树上有一个传统，只挂食物挂饰。是的。这是包子吗？这些是吗？它们就像是饺子。对。这就是我想不起来的那个词，饺子。
Yeah. At lunch, you were literally eating this meal when the word I couldn't think of, dumplings. Yeah. For lunch, you were literally eating this meal when we were having a meeting. This is incredible. Yes. I love it, thank you. For your food tree. Yeah.
对。在吃午饭时，你 literalmente 正在吃这顿饭，当时我想不起来的词就是饺子。对。吃午饭时，我们开会的时候，你 literalmente 正在吃这顿饭。这太不可思议了。是的。我很喜欢，谢谢。为了你的食物圣诞树。耶。
So cute. I'll have to total up this year's calories of a tree. Each year I total it up. All right, Cassie, open yours. Clearly I have a theme whenever I shop for you and I'm so sorry. What can it be? Ooh.
太可爱了。我得算算今年树上的卡路里总数了。我每年都会统计。好了，凯西，拆你的吧。显然我给你买东西时总有一个主题，非常抱歉。会是什么呢？哦。
Ah, a basketball ornament. I love it. I'm gonna, we're gonna mix it up next year if we are. I truly love basketball so you can't go wrong. I know you do and Jenna was like, Ange, I found the perfect one for Sam. So, you know, we're leaning into what you guys like. Yeah, thank you.
啊，一个篮球挂饰。我太喜欢了。如果可以的话，我们明年要换个风格。我真心喜欢篮球，所以选这个准没错。我知道你喜欢，珍娜当时说：“安吉，我给萨姆找到了完美的挂饰。”所以，你知道的，我们顺应了你们的喜好。对，谢谢。
All right, Angela, here's your little gift. Guess what? It's an ornament. Look at which one it is. Okay. Macy's has all these ornaments from Holiday Lane and they are so cute. They've got a whole section of food, Sam. Oh, really?
好吧，安吉拉，这是你的小礼物。你猜怎么着？是一个挂饰。看看是哪一个。好的。梅西百货有来自 Holiday Lane 的所有这些挂饰，它们太可爱了。它们有一整片食物区，萨姆。哦，真的吗？
Ornaments that are food. Tons of food ornaments. Really? Yes. And they have animals and they have everything. Mm-hmm. Okay. Jenna, you really went a lot,
做成食物形状的挂饰。成吨的食物挂饰。真的吗？是的。它们还有动物形状的，应有尽有。嗯。好吧，珍娜，你真的用了好多，
you went heavy on the tissue here. Sorry about that. Oh, it's a cheese board! Whoa! It's a cheese board ornament, I thought I could remind you of our giant cheese cart from our celebration dinner. Oh, I love it.
你在这里用了厚厚的一层包装纸。不好意思啊。哦，是一个奶酪盘！哇！是一个奶酪盘挂饰，我想它可以让你想起我们庆祝晚宴上的那个巨型奶酪车。哦，我太喜欢了。
And just the fact that I love cheese. It's so much. Yeah, it's great. It's perfectly hand. All right, Jenna, there's yours. Here we go. Oh, it's an I Love New York ornament. It's your happy place.
仅仅因为我太爱奶酪了。非常喜欢。是的，太棒了。手工非常精细。好吧，珍娜，那是你的礼物。我们来吧。哦，是一个“我爱纽约”的挂饰。这是你的快乐老家。
It is my happy place. Yay. All right. Well, now that everybody has something to hang on their tree, Sam, would you like to start? This is your big gift. OK. And Sam, you are not easy to shop for,
这确实是我的快乐老家。耶。好吧。好了，既然每个人都有东西可以挂在树上了，萨姆，你想开始吗？这是你的大礼物。好的。萨姆，要给你挑礼物真不容易，
but I found this on the Macy's gift guide, and I thought of you. Jenna drew Sam, and I drew Cassie, basically, in our gift giving. Oh, it's a camera. It looks like an like a 35 millimeter camera. Yes. Oh, this is awesome.
但我是在梅西百货的礼品指南上找到这个的，我就想到了你。在送礼环节，基本上是珍娜抽中了萨姆，而我抽中了凯西。哦，是一个相机。它看起来像一台35毫米胶片相机。是的。哦，这太棒了。
Thank you. OK, it looks because I know you love to take Polaroids and stuff. And you like old timey camera. I do, yeah. You like some old tech. This is great. Thank you. You're welcome.
谢谢。好的，因为它看起来……因为我知道你喜欢拍宝丽来之类的照片。而且你喜欢老式相机。我确实喜欢，对。你喜欢一些老式科技产品。太棒了。谢谢。不客气。
And it looks like it's a disposable camera, but it's actually reusable. OK, good. I won't throw it away. Don't throw it away. That's why I got you a whole pack of film it's actually reusable. Okay, good, I won't throw it away. Don't throw it away, that's why I got you a whole pack of film to go with it. Oh, wow, thank you. It's got this really cool graphic design too.
它看起来像是一次性相机，但实际上它是可重复使用的。好的，太好了，我不会把它扔掉的。别扔掉。这就是为什么我给你买了一整包胶卷，它其实是可以重复使用的。好的，太好了，我不会把它扔掉的。别扔掉，这就是为什么我给你买了一整包胶卷来搭配它。哦，哇，谢谢。它的平面设计也太酷了吧。
It's a retrospect killer acid. Yeah, killer acid is, it's like art. Yeah, all the pictures look like creepy camping art. I like it a lot. Lee said it was cool, so. This is very cool. Thank you. Oh yeah. Oh, it looks good. You just unwrapped it. Yeah. Let me see Sam. Hold it up. Isn't it fun. Oh, it looks really cute. Okay. All right. Thank you. Okay. Here we go. Welcome stickers too. Okay. Now it's a gift.
是 Retrospect Killer Acid 品牌的。对，Killer Acid，有点像艺术品。对，所有的照片看起来都像诡异的露营艺术品。我很喜欢。莉说这很酷，所以。这非常酷。谢谢。哦，是的。哦，看起来不错。你刚刚拆开它。嗯。让我看看，萨姆。举起来。是不是很有趣。哦，看起来真可爱。好吧。好吧。谢谢。好的。我们来吧。欢迎贴纸也来了。好吧。这下才像个礼物。
Okay. Cassie, your turn. This is your big one. You said something the other day in studio that just stuck in my brain and I thought, well, maybe she might like this. Ooh, it's a blazer. It's a sweater blazer. Ooh, even better. But you were saying you always wear the cutest jackets and you came in the other day and I sneakily said, oh, that's so cute.
好了。凯西，轮到你了。这是你的大件礼物。你前几天在录音室说的一句话刚好留在了我的脑海里，我想，也许她会喜欢这个。哦，是一件西装外套。是一件毛衣西装外套。哦，那更好。不过你之前说过你总是穿着最可爱的夹克，你前几天走进来的时候，我偷偷地说，哦，那太可爱了。
What size is that jacket? You got me. I never clocked that at all. It's so cute. It's by On 34th created for Macy's and I thought you could dress it up or dress it down. I love it. Thank you so much.
那件夹克是什么尺码的？你被我套出话了。我完全没注意到。太可爱了。这是 On 34th 为梅西百货专门设计的，我觉得你可以穿得很正式，也可以穿得很休闲。我很喜欢。非常感谢。
Okay, and here is your gift and And I know you're gonna like it because you put it on our Macy's gift guide list. I did want this. Okay, so I tend to put things on our storefront that I actually want for myself. I'm guilty of that as well. I love it. Wow.
好吧，这是你的礼物，我知道你会喜欢，因为你把它加到了我们的梅西百货礼品指南清单上了。我确实想要这个。好吧，我倾向于把那些我自己其实很想拥有的东西放到我们的网店里。我也有同样的毛病。我很喜欢。哇。
It's a little cross body saddle bag. Yes, it's by On 34th. Yay. Okay, Jenna, here is your big gift. This is something you were saying you wanted. So I just got you exactly what you've been talking about. Oh my gosh, I can't even think of anything I've been saying that I wanted.
是一个小巧的斜挎马鞍包。是的，是 On 34th 品牌的。耶。好吧，珍娜，这是你的大件礼物。这是你之前说过你想要的东西。所以我正好给你买下了你一直念叨的东西。哦天哪，我都想不起来我有说过自己想要什么。
Oh my goodness. It's a, what do you call that thing that you bring your lunch in to work? A lunch pail. So Jenna brings her lunch almost every week when we record and this is an insulated lunch bag. Oh lady, thank you. And look at the little handle.
哦天哪。这是一个……你把午饭带到工作地点去的那个叫什么来着？饭盒。所以珍娜每次录音几乎每周都会带午饭，这是一个保温午餐包。哦，天哪，谢谢。你看这个小提手。
It is so stinking cute. Here, open it up. Look, it's pretty spacious. Wow. Oh my gosh. This is This is something that I really needed that I just have never bought myself Sometimes I bring in soup and I put it in the same bag as my computer And I just like hope that I carry it up right. I know Right? That Just tempting God.
它真是太可爱了。来，打开它。看，空间挺宽敞的。哇。哦天哪。这正是我真正需要却一直没舍得给自己买的东西。有时候我带汤来，把它和我的电脑放在同一个包里，我只能祈祷我能把它端正地拿上去。我懂。对吧？简直是在拿神开玩笑。
That is- You need to live your life that way. So insane. Thank you. It's a black and white stripe sort of pattern and I just thought it looked cute. I absolutely love it. This is so fun.
就是——你得按那种方式过日子。太疯狂了。谢谢你。这是一种黑白相间的条纹图案，我觉得它看起来很可爱。我绝对超爱它。这太有趣了。
It's by Zulay Kitchen and it's on our storefront as well. Well, everyone, you too can get your holiday shopping done with Macy's this year. Your one-stop shop for everyone on your list. And I was saying when I came in today that I have become slightly obsessed with the Macy's.com gift guide. I am truly using it to find gifts for everybody on my list. I'm also slightly obsessed with our gift guide. I'm enjoying putting up suggestions and all the gifts that we gave away today
它是 Zulay Kitchen 品牌的，在我们的小店主页上也能买到。好了，各位，今年你们也可以通过梅西百货轻松搞定节日购物啦。这是满足你清单上所有人的购齐商店。我今天来的时候就说过，我对梅西百货官网的礼物指南已经有点着迷了。我真的是在用它来为我清单上的每个人找礼物。我对我们自己的礼物指南也稍微有点着迷。我很享受提出建议，而且我们今天送出的所有礼物
will be on our gift guide and more. We're adding stuff all the time. Yeah, we actually sat side by side with our laptops and literally put the storefront together and we're like, ooh this, ooh that, ooh this. I know. And you can shop our favorites this holiday season directly from our Macy's gift guide storefront
都会出现在我们的礼物指南上，还有更多好物。我们一直在添加新东西。对，我们其实是并排坐着，拿着笔记本电脑，真正把小店主页拼凑了起来，我们当时就说，噢，这个，噢，那个，噢，这个。我懂。这个节日季，你就可以直接在我们的梅西礼物指南小店主页上
by visiting the link in our Instagram bio. Yes, head to our Instagram bio for the link to shop directly from our Macy's gift guide storefront. Let Macy's be your guide to gifting. Yay, happy holidays! Thank you! Happy holidays! Merry Christmas.
通过访问我们 Instagram 个人简介里的链接来购买我们精选的心仪好物。没错，前往我们的 Instagram 个人简介，点击链接即可直接在我们的梅西礼物指南小店主页购买。让梅西百货成为你的送礼指南。耶，节日快乐！谢谢！节日快乐！圣诞快乐。
Well, I think that was a pretty successful gift exchange. And you know, Dunder Mifflin had some pretty epic gift exchanges. Well, they sure did. Of course. The most famous is probably the Yankee Swap from Christmas Party Season 2. But Ange, my favorite memory from that episode is an off-camera memory, which we shared in our book, which is that we all wanted to see if Angela could fit inside of a large Christmas bag. Yeah, there was one on set.
好吧，我觉得那真是一场相当成功的礼物交换。你知道的，邓德米夫林公司也进行过一些相当史诗级的礼物交换。没错，他们当然有。当然。最著名的可能就是第二季《圣诞派对》里的洋基交换（Yankee Swap）。不过，安琪，我从那一集中最喜欢的记忆是一个幕后记忆，我们在书中分享过，那就是我们所有人都想看看安吉拉能不能塞进一个大圣诞袋子里。对，片场确实有一个。
A big gift bag. Yeah. And you fit. I did. I crawled in it. And then you guys all took a picture of me and we'll put that in our stories. Yes, we put it in our book, but you need to put that in stories. But in terms of an episode gift exchange,
一个大礼品袋。对。而你真的塞进去了。我确实进去了。我爬了进去。然后你们所有人都给我拍了张照，我们会把它发到限时动态里。对，我们把它放进了书里，但你们得把它发到限时动态里。不过就剧中的礼物交换而言，
my favorite is actually from season eight, Christmas Wishes. It's the montage where Dwight is doing his air guitar and it flashes to everybody exchanging gifts. Yeah, that is a really sweet one. Yeah. Well, you know, the office has so many great Christmas episodes and I loved our dueling Santas
我最喜欢的其实来自第八季的《圣诞心愿》。那是德怀特在假弹吉他、镜头闪过每个人在交换礼物的蒙太奇片段。对，那真是一个非常温馨的片段。对呀。不过你知道的，办公室有那么多精彩的圣诞剧集，而我最喜欢我们那场针锋相对的圣诞老人
in season six in the Secret Santa episode. Oh, is that the one where it's Phyllis versus Michael, right? Yes. So Phyllis versus Michael, but then also Bob Vance shows up as Santa. That's right.
出自第六季的《秘密圣诞老人》那一集。哦，就是菲莉丝对阵迈克尔的那一集对吧？没错。所以是菲莉丝对阵迈克尔，但同时鲍勃·万斯（Bob Vance）也作为圣诞老人现身了。没错。
We end up having three Santas, but Phyllis has such a great talking head about being Santa. I love it so much. And I feel like we need to hear it. I have been wanting to be Santa for years. I believe I have the right temperament and the figure to do the job well. I slipped a note to Jim 11 weeks ago and he said I could do it. Oh, it's been a long journey, but I'm Santa Claus. Aw, I love Santa Phyllis.
我们最后出现了三个圣诞老人，但菲莉丝关于当圣诞老人的那段独白（talking head）真是太棒了。我太喜欢了。我觉得我们得听听看。我多年来一直想当圣诞老人。我相信我有合适的气质和身材能把这份工作做好。我11周前给吉姆塞了一张纸条，他说我可以。哦，这是一段漫长的旅程，但我就是圣诞老人。啊，我爱圣诞老人菲莉丝。
I know, Santa Phyllis is so sweet. Well, you know, Jenna, all this talk about Santas on the set of The Office makes me think of a story. I wanna share about meeting someone who became a Santa's helper. And moms and dads out there, if you're listening, you might want to listen to this part first before you share it with your family in any little ears.
我懂，圣诞老人菲莉丝太可爱了。好吧，你知道的，珍娜，所有这些关于《办公室》片场圣诞老人的讨论让我想起了一个故事。我想分享一段关于遇到一个成为圣诞老人助手的人的故事。各位爸爸妈妈，如果你们在听，在和你们的家人及任何小耳朵分享之前，你们可能想先听听这一部分。
Yes, good point. You might be driving to your holiday stuff right now, and that's a good tip, Ange. Yeah, it's a great story, and I'm excited to share it. This is the best story. When you were making your Hallmark Christmas movie in Vancouver, you left me a message that I was like, you have to tell this
是的，说得好。你们现在可能正开车去过节的路上，这是一个好建议，安琪。对，这是一个很棒的故事，我很高兴能分享它。这是最棒的故事。当你在温哥华拍摄你的 Hallmark 圣诞电影时，你给我留了一条语音留言，当时我就觉得，你一定要在
on the podcast sometimes. So I feel like this is the perfect time. I agree. So yeah, like Jenna said, I was working on my Hallmark Christmas movie and to get to the set, the location was about an hour from where I was staying. So every day they would send a transportation driver that worked on the movie to drive me
播客里把这个讲出来。所以我觉得这是个绝佳的时机。我同意。所以，就像珍娜说的，我当时在拍我的 Hallmark 圣诞电影，为了去片场，那个地点离我住的地方大约有一个小时的车程。所以每天他们都会派一个在电影里工作的运输司机来开车送我
to the set. And one of the guys that drove me was named Dan Cresswell. And when you have an hour drive, you get to know someone. You start chatting. And on one of our drives, I asked him, oh, are you going to go work on another movie? Because a lot of the crew was saying they already had another job, another Christmas movie lined up. And he said, no, I'm about to take my three month yearly break. And I thought three months off. I was so curious. I said, well, what do you do during
去片场。其中一个开车送过我的司机名叫丹·克雷斯韦尔（Dan Cresswell）。当你要坐一个小时的车时，你就会开始了解一个人。你们会开始聊天。在其中的一次车程中，我问他：“哦，你要去拍另一部电影吗？”因为很多剧组人员都说他们已经安排好了另一份工作，另一部圣诞电影。而他说：“不，我准备开始我为期三个月的年度休假了。”当时我想：休假三个月？我太好奇了。我说：“那你在这期间都做些什么呢？”
these three months? And he said, well, I'm a professional Santa. And from October to December, I start work as Santa. And then I know you, Ange, you were like, I have so many questions, tell me more. I did, I was like, I have so many questions, and we have an hour car ride, so we're gonna get into it. First of all, lady, I had to ask him, how did this start? How do you just kind of wake up one day and say,
他说：“哦，我是一个职业圣诞老人。从10月到12月，我开始做圣诞老人。”然后我知道你，安琪，你当时肯定在想：我有好多问题，快多告诉我一点。我确实是，我当时就觉得：我有好多问题，而且我们有一小时的车程，所以我们要深入了解一下。首先，女士，我不得不问他：这一切是怎么开始的？你怎么能有一天突然醒来然后说：
I'm gonna be a Santa? Well, does he look like Santa? Does he grow out a beard and everything? He does not look like a Santa at all. Okay. And he will be very quick to tell you by the way that all the Santas you see they are Santa's helpers. Mm-hmm. They're not their real Santa. Mm-hmm. They're all Santa's helpers for everyone listening out there. That's right. So all the kids listening out there, Dan wanted you to know that he's a Santa's helper. Because it's a busy season
我要当个圣诞老人？那他长得像圣诞老人吗？他会留胡子什么的吗？他一点也不像圣诞老人。好吧。顺便说一句，他会非常快地告诉你，你见到的所有圣诞老人，他们其实都是圣诞老人的助手。嗯嗯。他们并不是真正的圣诞老人。嗯嗯。对所有在听的听众来说，他们都是圣诞老人的助手。没错。所以所有在听的小朋友们，丹想让你们知道，他是一个圣诞老人的助手。因为这是一个忙碌的季节，
and Santa needs all the help he can get. That's right. So anyways, I'm like, but Dan, seriously, when did you start doing this? He said, well, it all started about seven years ago. I was earning extra money delivering pizzas. And it was November and my son Zachary was 11 years old at the time and he said,
圣诞老人需要他能得到的所有帮助。没错。所以无论如何，我就说：“但是丹，说真的，你是什么时候开始做这个的？”他说：“这一切大约始于七年前。我当时靠送披萨赚点外快。那是11月，我的儿子扎卡里（Zachary）当时11岁，他说：”
Dad, you should dress up as Santa when you deliver pizza. I think that would be really fun and maybe you'd get better tips. That's smart kid. It's so cute. And Dan kind of laughed and then he thought about it and then he was at Walmart and there was a Santa suit for $50 so he decided to give it a go.
“爸爸，你送披萨的时候应该扮成圣诞老人。我觉得那会非常有趣，说不定你能拿到更多小费。”真是个聪明的孩子。太可爱了。丹先是笑了一下，然后他考虑了一下，接着他在沃尔玛看到了一套50美元的圣诞老人服装，于是他决定尝试一下。
He said his very first pizza delivery dressed as Santa, a dad opened the door and his little girls were standing there with him and they lost their minds. They were so excited that Santa had come and brought them pizza and the dad said, would it be okay if I take a picture of you with my daughters for Christmas? Dan said, sure. And he said the whole family was so thrilled.
他说他第一次穿着圣诞老人服装去送披萨时，一位爸爸打开了门，他的一小女儿们正站在那里，她们当场惊呆了。她们看到圣诞老人来给她们送披萨，兴奋极了，那位爸爸说：“为了圣诞节，我和我的女儿们一起跟你拍张照可以吗？”丹说：“当然可以。”他说全家人都开心极了。
And after that, he did get a nice little tip and he thought, hmm, maybe there's something to this. He said that even as he would drive around town delivering pizzas in a Santa suit, people would honk and wave. They'd want to take their picture like through the car window. And he loved it and he told his wife, maybe I could do this as an actual business. He didn't know anything about it or how to go about it, lady.
在那之后，他确实拿到了一小笔不错的小费，他想：嗯，这或许大有可为。他说，甚至当他穿着圣诞老人服装开着车在镇上送披萨时，人们也会按喇叭并向他挥手。他们甚至想隔着车窗给他拍照。他很喜欢这样，他告诉他妻子，或许我可以把这当成一门真正的生意。他对这行一无所知，也不知道该怎么着手，女士。
He googled. He was a Santa who googled? Yes. He said he found a Santa school in Vancouver. It was a four day course, Friday through Monday. You get to learn how to become a professional Santa in marketing, et cetera. And after that, he got a job as a Santa for Cabela's, which is very similar to like our Bass Pro Shop.
他开始谷歌搜索。他是一个会谷歌搜索的圣诞老人？对。他说他在温哥华找到了一所圣诞老人学校。那是一个为期四天的课程，从周五到周一。你可以学习如何成为一名专业的圣诞老人，包括市场营销等等。在这之后，他在 Cabela's 找到了一份圣诞老人的工作，这非常类似于我们的 Bass Pro Shop。
Okay. And he worked there for two years. He kinda did some highlighting at the mall, but he really wanted to start his own Santa business. This was his dream. And his boss at the Cabela place got him a much better Santa suit. And he was like, ooh, I'm gonna need all the Santa gear
好吧。他在那里工作了两年。他在商场里做过一些亮相活动，但他真的很想创办自己的圣诞老人业务。这是他的梦想。他在 Cabela's 的老板给他弄了一套好得多的圣诞老人服装。他当时就想：哦，如果我要把这当成我自己的生意，我需要全套的圣诞老人装备，
if I'm gonna make this my own business. And I might need one or two more suits. So he asked her, where do you get your Santa suits? And she said, uh-uh, I'm gonna make this my own business and I might need one or two more suits. So we asked her, where do you get your Santa suits? And she said, uh-uh, I'm not telling you. Why wouldn't she give up the details about where to get a good Santa suit? I guess she's the go-to for good Santa suits in Vancouver and she didn't wanna give up her source.
而且我可能还需要再多一两套服装。所以他问她：“你在哪儿买的圣诞老人服装？”然后她说：“呃-呃，我可不告诉你。”为什么她不肯透露在哪能买到好的圣诞老人服装的细节呢？我猜她在温哥华是那种专门购买优质圣诞老人服装的人，她不想泄露她的货源。
Wow. I know. So he really had to mom detective it. He joined a bunch of online communities of working Santas. He found a site called hiresanta.com. I guess it was featured on the TV show Shark Tank. And you wanna know the best part? He finally found where to get a good Santa suit. Where?
哇。我懂。所以他真的不得不像妈妈侦探一样去查。他加入了许多在线的职业圣诞老人社区。他找到了一个叫 hiresanta.com 的网站。我猜它曾在电视节目《创智赢家》（Shark Tank）中亮相。你想知道最棒的部分是什么吗？他终于找到了在哪里可以买到好的圣诞老人服装。在哪？
Adele Hollywood Costumes here in Los Angeles. Oh. Mm-hmm. He said he has two suits, the Coca-Cola Santa suit and the traditional Santa suit. They run about $1,400 each. Whoa. Yeah, but they're really nice, he said, and they last a long time.
就在洛杉矶的 Adele 好莱坞服装店（Adele Hollywood Costumes）。哦。嗯嗯。他说他有两套服装，一套是可口可乐圣诞老人服装，另一套是传统圣诞老人服装。每套大约要1400美元。哇。对，但他说真的很好，而且能穿很久。
But that wasn't it. Now he needed a good beard. He does not have a beard. He has short brown hair. He needed a beard. He needed the full look. The first beard he bought was in California. It was made from real hair and cost $1,500.
但还不止于此。现在他需要一顶好胡子。他自己没有胡子。他留着短棕发。他需要一顶胡子。他需要全套的造型。他买的第一顶胡子是在加利福尼亚。那是用真发制作的，花了他1500美元。
Wow. Yeah, but it didn't hold up as well as he liked when kids would tug on it because he said they tug on your beard. Okay. So then through this community of Santas, he found a lady that makes handmade beards in China using yak hair.
哇。对，但当小孩子们拉扯它时，它并没有他希望的那么经久耐用，因为他说孩子们会拉扯你的胡子。好吧。于是通过这个圣诞老人社区，他找到了一位在中国用牦牛毛制作手工胡子的女士。
Wow. Uh-huh, he said it's the best Santa beard out there. They average around 900 to $1,000 Canadian. This is a real investment. It really is. I really like his integrity here though. He wants to look like a really good Santa. If he's gonna start his own business,
哇。嗯嗯，他说这是市面上最好的圣诞老人胡子。它们的均价大约在900到1000加元左右。这真是一笔不小的投资。确实是的。不过我真的很喜欢他身上的这种正直。他想看起来像个真正优秀的圣诞老人。如果他要创办自己的生意，
he wants to be the real deal what he told me I have to imagine that these are Santa standards Mm-hmm and that the real Santa Wants his helpers to be as authentic as possible. Mm-hmm, and he showed me pictures of his suits. They're beautiful They're like works of art. He also needed special Santa glasses and he got those from spangle the clown It's a website. Guess what? He's a clown and a Santa. Oh! He even found a website where you can get accessories. Like he has a North Pole driver's license that he can show kids.
他想要成为货真价实的那个，他跟我说 我必须想象这些就是圣诞老人的标准 嗯嗯 并且真正的圣诞老人 希望他的助手们尽可能地原汁原味。嗯嗯，他还给我看了他服装的照片。太美了。它们就像艺术品一样。他还需要特殊的圣诞老人眼镜，他是从一个叫“小丑斯潘格尔”（Spangle the Clown）那买的。那是个网站。你猜怎么着？他既是个小丑又是个圣诞老人。哦！他甚至找到了一个可以买配件的网站。比如他有一张北极驾照，可以出示给孩子们看。
It's so cute, lady. He texted me his picture. It's so adorable. But now he had everything he needed to start his own business, but he didn't know how to put on the beard. How do you put on the beard. How do you put on this beard? How do you get it to stay? How do you do the makeup? And here he is driving on these movie sets, so he went into the hair and makeup trailer on one of the movie sets. I would hope so. They taught him how to do the whole look. He says it takes him about 45 minutes.
太可爱了，女士。他把照片发给我了。太萌了。但现在他拥有了创办自己生意所需的一切，但他却不知道怎么戴上这胡子。你怎么戴上这胡子。你怎么戴上这胡子？你怎么让它固定住？你怎么化特效妆？而当时他正在这些电影片场开车，所以他走进了其中一个电影片场的发型和化妆房车。我希望如此。他们教了他如何完成整个造型。他说这大约需要45分钟。
He puts on the beard with the spearmint gum and it really adheres that way. If kids tug at it, it's like his own hair. It's not coming off. And the hair and makeup department on the movie, they thought it was so fun. They gave him a nickname, because his name is Dan, but he's a Santa. So everyone on the set calls him Danta.
他用绿箭口香糖（spearmint gum）把胡子粘上去，这样真的能固定住。如果孩子们拉扯它，感觉就像他自己的头发一样。是不会掉下来的。电影里的发型和化妆部门觉得这太有趣了。他们给他起了一个绰号，因为他的名字叫丹（Dan），但他是个圣诞老人（Santa）。所以片场每个人都叫他“丹塔”（Danta）。
And now he has his own business. He is his own Santa. He gets bookings starting as early as July. He said that October is photo time. He does photo shoots with people. November, December is the big corporate gigs and home visits. And one of his biggest goals as Santa
现在他有了自己的生意。他成了他自己的圣诞老人。他最早从7月就开始接预约了。他说10月是拍照的时间。他和人们一起进行照片拍摄。11月、12月则是大型公司活动和上门拜访的旺季。作为圣诞老人，他最大的目标之一
was to be in one of these holiday movies that he works on as a transportation driver. And it finally happened. He's been trying for four years. and this year he's in a Hallmark Christmas movie as a Santa. As a Santa? Yeah! Santa is gonna be in a movie. Yes! It's called Leah's Perfect Gift. It's on Hallmark and he told me he only has one big dream left as Santa. What is it? He wants to someday go to the world's oldest Santa school. Where's
就是在他作为运输司机参与工作的其中一部节日电影里出镜。而这终于实现了。他尝试了四年，今年他终于在一部 Hallmark 圣诞电影里扮演圣诞老人。扮演圣诞老人？对！圣诞老人要出现在电影里了。太棒了！这部电影叫《利亚的完美礼物》（Leah's Perfect Gift）。它将在 Hallmark 上映，他告诉我，他作为圣诞老人只剩下一个伟大的梦想了。是什么？他希望有一天能去世界上最古老的圣诞老人学校。那在
that? In Midland, Michigan. It was established in 1937. It's called Charles W. Howard Santa Claus School. On their website it has this quote, he heirs who thinks Santa enters through the chimney. Santa enters through the heart. Oh, I know. And lastly I said, Dan, why do you like being a Santa's helper? And he said he loves making people happy. He said the way the kids' eyes just light up when they see Santa, he said you see hope, you see wonder. The parents are so happy. He said every day is something different, but it's always joyful. And Dan's son is now 21 years old. He said he's so proud of his dad and it's all because he told him to dress
哪？在密歇根州的米德兰（Midland）。它成立于1937年。它叫查尔斯·W·霍华德圣诞老人学校（Charles W. Howard Santa Claus School）。他们的官网上有这样一句话：“认为圣诞老人从烟囱进入的人就错了。圣诞老人是从心里进入的。”哦，我懂。最后我说：“丹，你为什么喜欢当圣诞老人的助手？”他说他喜欢让人们快乐。他说当孩子们看到圣诞老人时，他们的眼睛放光的那种方式，他说你能看到希望，看到惊奇。父母们也无比开心。他说每天都不一样，但总是充满欢乐。而且丹的儿子现在21岁了。他说他为自己的爸爸感到骄傲，这一切都源于当年他告诉他去
up as Santa to deliver pizzas. I mean now I'm crying. That was so beautiful. I know. And you know what else is beautiful about it Angela is that this is just something I love about you and your curiosity about people and the things that interest people. It's true, if you sit on a flight with Angela or if she's gonna drive you for an hour, she's gonna get it out of you. She is, she is gonna, she wants to know what makes you tick.
扮成圣诞老人去送披萨。我的天，我现在都要哭了。那太美好了。我知道。而且关于这一点，安吉拉，还有什么美好之处在于，这正是我所喜爱的关于你的一点——你对人们以及人们感兴趣的事物的那种好奇心。真的，如果你和安吉拉坐同一趟航班，或者如果她要开车送你一个小时，她一定会从你嘴里把话套出来。她会的，她绝对会的，她想要弄清楚是什么在驱动着你。
But it's such a beautiful thing. And I just love that you shared his story with everybody. Well thank you lady I just really enjoyed getting to know him it's a whole world I knew nothing about. I didn't know there was Santa school. I know. There's a whole program. Yeah and I'm gonna share Dan's website in our Instagram if you're in the Vancouver area and you need a Santa, you'll have all his information. Thank you, Dan. Well, you know, Angela, I think that the real Santa
但这真是一件美好的事。我太喜欢你跟所有人分享他的故事了。噢，谢谢你，女士。我真的很享受了解他，这是一个我一无所知的全新世界。我以前甚至不知道还有圣诞老人学校。我知道。有一个完整的项目。对，我会在我们的 Instagram 上分享丹的网站，如果你在温哥华地区并且需要一个圣诞老人，你就会拥有他所有的信息。谢谢你，丹。好吧，你知道的，安吉拉，我觉得真正的圣诞老人
is the Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade Santa. It's certainly the first time we see the real Santa for the season, and I have a little story about that. Oh, yeah? Yes. My family went to New York for Thanksgiving one year and once we were there, we realized that we were staying on the Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade route.
就是梅西百货感恩节游行里的圣诞老人。这当然是我们在这个季节第一次见到真正的圣诞老人，我刚好有一个关于这个的小故事。哦，是吗？对的！我家里人有一年去纽约过感恩节，等我们到了那里之后，我们才意识到我们住的地方正好在梅西百货感恩节游行的路线沿途。
How fun, how old were your kids? Little, they were young. And lady, I love the Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade. I love all the musical numbers that they do. I get to see the Broadway numbers twice a year at the Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade and the Tony's, and I live for it. I love the Macy's Day Parade. Well, we were super excited when we realized we were on the route. It's really long. It's
太有趣了，你孩子多大了？很小，他們還小。而且天啊，我好喜歡梅西感恩節大遊行。我喜歡他們所有的歌舞表演。我一年能在梅西感恩節大遊行和東尼獎上看到兩次百老匯歌舞，我就是為此而活的。我超愛梅西大遊行。嗯，當我們意識到我們剛好在遊行路線上時，我們超級興奮。真的很長。大概
like two and a half miles, you know? it goes all the way from up by the Natural History Museum, all the way down to Macy's Herald Square. We were staying about halfway maybe. So the first couple days before the parade, you can actually go up by the museum and you can watch them blow up all the balloons. Yes. And it's just so fun. So here's the thing that happened though. On the day of the parade, we were all set to like go down to the end of the street where we were staying and just we got a free view of everything going by. It was crazy. But we overslept because we were on LA time.
有兩英里半左右，你知道嗎？它從自然歷史博物館附近一直延伸到梅西先驅廣場。我們住的地方大概在中間位置。所以在遊行前的頭幾天，你其實可以去博物館附近看他們充所有氣球。對。真的很有趣。不過事情是這樣的。在遊行當天，我們本來準備去我們住的那條街的盡頭，然後就能免費觀看所有東西從眼前經過。太瘋狂了。但我們睡過頭了，因為我們是洛杉磯時間。
So by the time we woke up and we ran to the end of the street, it was the last float going by. Oh no. Which is Santa on his sleigh. Oh, that's good. That's, this is a roller coaster. Yes. So we were like, oh, at least we got to see the Santa.
所以等我們醒來並跑到街盡頭時，剛好是最後一個花車經過。噢不。那是聖誕老人坐在他的雪橇上。噢，那還不錯。這真像坐雲霄飛車。對啊。所以我們當時想，噢，至少我們看到了聖誕老人。
And then we went back inside and we were having breakfast and coffee and we were watching the parade on TV. And it was really crazy because it was almost an hour before Santa got from where we were all the way down to in front of Macy's. But we were all excited because that meant that we saw Santa about an hour before everybody else saw Santa on TV. But it was a really, it's one of our fun family memories. I love that.
然後我們回屋裡吃早餐、喝咖啡，並在電視上看遊行。這真的很瘋狂，因為聖誕老人從我們那裡到梅西百貨正門，差不多花了一個小時。但我們都很興奮，因為這意味著我們比電視上每個人大約早一個小時看到了聖誕老人。但這真的是一個非常棒的家庭回憶。我好喜歡。
I, you know, it's so funny, Jenna, because I have such a great memory of the Macy's Day Parade when I was interning on Conan, and it couldn't be more different, but I wanna tell you. So here I am, I'm in my early 20s, I'm interning on Conan O'Brien when they used to tape at 30 Rockefeller Center. And it's the day before the Macy's Day Parade and they close all these
你知道嗎，珍娜，這太有趣了，因為我對梅西大遊行有一段超棒的回憶，那是我在柯南節目實習的時候，雖然情況完全不同，但我想告訴你。當時我才20出頭，在洛克菲勒中心30號錄製的《柯南·奧布萊恩秀》實習。那是梅西大遊行前的一天，他們封閉了沿途的
streets along the route, right? And it's in the morning and I'm walking to work and the street is closed. There's like no one on it and I see this man in a full suit, like a really nice suit with a nice coat and he is rollerblading with a briefcase through the street just like zooming by and as he goes by me I just said oh wow that's so cool and he goes my favorite day of the year I always skate to work on this day. Oh my gosh. Isn't that funny? Yes.
所有街道，對吧？那是早晨，我正走去上班，街上封閉了。上面幾乎沒什麼人，然後我看到一個穿著整套西裝的男人，一套非常好的西裝配一件漂亮的外套，他拿著公事包在街上溜直排輪，就像呼嘯而過一樣，當他從我身旁經過時，我只是說，噢哇，太酷了。他說我一年中最喜歡的日子，我這天總是滑冰上班。我的天啊。是不是很好笑？對。
And it was such a like visual, you know, to see this one lone skater in a suit in like an abandoned part of Manhattan. I'll never forget it. Okay. So lady, we have covered Office Christmas memories, Santa, gifts, but there's one more thing I wanna talk about. For me, another thing I love about the holidays
這真是一個很有視覺衝擊力的畫面，你知道的，看到曼哈頓荒涼的街道上只有一個穿西裝的溜冰者。我永遠不會忘記。好了。所以各位，我們已經聊過辦公室聖誕回憶、聖誕老人、禮物，但還有一件事我想聊聊。對我來說，我喜歡節日的另一個原因是
is the music. Oh yeah. This is the time of year when you walk through the mall and you hear all the holiday songs playing. I love it. And I wanted to ask the group, do you have a favorite holiday song? Like one that you look forward to hearing? I think Bing Crosby's White Christmas. Oh yes, yes. Well interestingly enough, Sam, I didn't know you were going to say that. But
音樂。噢對。這段時間走過購物中心，你會聽到所有播放的節日歌曲。我好喜歡。我想問問大家，你們有最喜歡的節日歌曲嗎？比如那種你很期待聽到的歌？我覺得是平克·克勞斯的《白色聖誕》。噢對，對。有趣的是，山姆，我不知道你會這麼說。但
did you know that according to the Guinness Book of World Records, White Christmas by Bing Crosby is not only the best-selling Christmas holiday single in the United States, but it was also the best-selling single of all time since the advent of recorded music with an estimated sales in excess of 50 million copies worldwide. Wow. I believe it also hasn't not been on the charts since it came out. Incredible. All right, Cassie, do you have a favorite Christmas song? Yes, I like Wham's Last Christmas. Oh, that's such a good one. That one charts the top often as well.
你知道嗎？根據金氏世界紀錄，平克·克勞斯的《白色聖誕》不僅是美國最暢銷的聖誕節日單曲，而且自錄音音樂問世以來，它也是有史以來最暢銷的單曲，據估計全球銷量超過5000萬張。哇。我相信自從它發行以來，它就一直停留在排行榜上。太不可思議了。好了，凱西，你有最喜歡的聖誕歌嗎？對，我喜歡威猛樂隊的《去年聖誕》。噢，那首真的很好聽。那首也經常名列前茅。
It's usually in the top five. And? I really did a deep dive on Christmas music. I don't normally have these stats off the top of my head. You know, it's so interesting because it's not so much just one song for me, but an album. Okay. So I love Elvis's Christmas album. Oh, yes.
通常在前五名。還有嗎？我真的深入研究了聖誕音樂。我腦海裡通常沒有這些數據。你知道，這很有趣，因為對我來說與其說是一首歌，不如說是一張專輯。好吧。我超愛貓王的聖誕專輯。噢，對。
It's so good. You know, his Silent Night, Holy Night is really beautiful. But then he also has Santa Claus is Back in Town. And that's like a really fun one. But I just love that album. It's interesting you say that, Angela, because my favorite Christmas song is also a favorite album.
真的很好聽。你知道，他的《平安夜，聖神夜》真的很美。但他也有一首《聖誕老人回城了》。那首真的很好玩。但我就是超愛那專輯。安琪拉，你這麼說真有趣，因為我最喜歡的聖誕歌也是我最喜歡的專輯。
I went through this phase where I got really into vinyl records, and my mom gave me her old record collection, and one of the records in the collection was a Frank Sinatra Christmas album. And I do bring out our little turntable and put it down by the Christmas tree. This is the first album that I play every season when we're decorating the tree and the first song on the album is Frank Sinatra's Jingle Bells and it's my
我曾經歷過一個非常迷黑膠唱片的階段，我媽媽把她的舊唱片收藏送給了我，收藏中的其中一張唱片就是法蘭克·辛納屈的聖誕專輯。我確實會搬出我們的小唱盤機，把它放在聖誕樹旁。這是我每個季節裝飾聖誕樹時播放的第一張專輯，專輯的第一首歌就是法蘭克·辛納屈的《叮叮噹》，這是我的
favorite and I'm going to play it. Yay! I love those J-I-M-G-L-E bells, oh Those holiday J-I-M-G-L-E bells, oh Those heavenly J-I-M-G-L-E-V-E-Double L-S I love those J-I-M-G-L-E bells, oh Jingle bells, jingle bells, jingle all the way Oh, blue eyes. I know. You just sing me right into Christmas, mister.
最愛，我要把它放出來。耶！我愛那些叮叮噹，噢，那些節日的叮叮噹，噢，那些天堂般的叮叮噹，我愛那些叮叮噹，噢，叮叮噹，叮叮噹，一路叮噹響，噢，藍眼睛。我知道。先生，你簡稱把我們唱進了聖誕節。
Who are you right now? I don't know. I like it. You guys, you know, since we're talking holiday music, I have to give a shout out to our dear friend, Kate Flannery, because she has a great Christmas album with Jane Lynch called A Swingin' Little Christmas. Oh, yes.
你現在是誰？我不知道。我喜歡這樣。各位，既然我們在聊節日音樂，我必須向我們親愛的朋友凱特·弗蘭納里致敬，因為她和珍·林奇出過一張很棒的聖誕專輯，叫《搖擺小聖誕》。噢，對。
And I also have that. It's so fun. She does a show this time of year. It's a super fun holiday show. And I just always love to give her a shout out. Well, we featured a lot of holiday music in our office Christmas episodes. Angela, you played us little drummer boy
我也有那張。真的很有趣。她每年這個時候都會舉辦一場演出。這是一個超級有趣的節日表演。我總是喜歡向她致敬。我們在辦公室的聖誕劇集中播放了很多節日音樂。安琪拉，你在節目開頭
at the top of the episode. We talked about when Dwight does his air guitar to Christmas Eve, Sarajevo 1224. That's the heavy metal medley of Christmas songs performed by the Trans-Siberian Orchestra. But in general, Dunder Mifflin Christmas parties just love to bust out the karaoke and the microphones and we did not limit ourselves to holiday songs. For example, in Benihana Christmas when we had the dueling Christmas parties,
為我們播放了《小鼓手》。我們聊到德懷特對著《薩拉熱窩聖誕夜1224》彈空氣吉他。那是跨西伯利亞交樂團演出的聖誕歌曲重金屬串燒。但總體來說，鄧德米夫林的聖誕派對就是喜歡拿出卡拉OK和麥克風，而且我們不限於節日歌曲。例如，在《班尼漢娜聖誕節》中，當我們有兩個對打的聖誕派對時，
we have Daryl on the keyboard and Kevin singing and I thought we should listen. And I'm here to remind you of the mess you left when you went away. It's not fair to deny me of the cross I bear that you give to me. You, you, you, you, you, you, you ought to know. That's it. There you go. Yeah, it worked oughta know. That's it, there you go. That worked out. I love it. I remember it like I was there when Brian is coming and was like, Yo, yo, yo.
我們有達里爾彈鍵盤，凱文唱歌，我覺得我們應該聽聽看。我來提醒你，你離開時留下的爛攤子。拒絕承受你給我的十字架是不公平的。你，你，你，你，你，你，你本該知道的。就是這樣。好了。對，奏效了，本該知道的。就是這樣，好了。這招管用。我好喜歡。我記憶猶新，就像我當時也在場一樣，布萊恩走過來就像是，喲，喲，喲。
And of course, in Secret Santa, there's the time when Dwight and Andy sing Green Day's Boulevard of Broken Dreams. Oh, I rewatched that one. We talked about that with Billy Joe Armstrong when we broke down that episode. Yeah, he was impressed with Ed. Yes, he was. Well, the holidays just are not the same without the music.
當然，在《秘密聖誕老人》中，有一次德懷特和安琪拉唱了綠日樂隊的《斷夢大道》。噢，我又重溫了那集。我們在剖析那一集時跟比利·喬·阿姆斯特朗聊過這個。對，他對艾德印象深刻。是的，確實如此。嗯，沒有音樂的節日就不一樣了。
And last year, I heard a story about holiday music that I have been dying to share on the podcast. I have been waiting for us to do some sort of holiday-themed episode. And here I go. Now, I mentioned been waiting for us to do some sort of holiday themed episode. And here I go. Now I mentioned before that White Christmas by Bing Crosby was the bestselling holiday single in the United States. But starting in 1991, we started tracking digital downloads as well as copies sold.
去年，我聽過一個關於節日音樂的故事，我一直渴望在播客中分享。我一直在等我們做某種節日主題的節目。我來了。現在，我之前提到平克·克勞斯的《白色聖誕》是美國最暢銷的節日單曲。但從1991年開始，我們開始追蹤數位下載量以及銷量。
And as of November 25th, 2016, the holiday single with the most digital downloads is Mariah Carey's 1994 track, All I Want for Christmas Is You. Let's listen. There is just one thing I need And I don't care about the present I only need the Christmas tree I don't need to hang my stocking Live upon the fireplace Santa Claus won't make me happy With a toy on a Christmas day
截至2016年11月25日，數位下載量最多的節日單曲是瑪麗亞·凱莉1994年的歌曲《你是我最想要的聖誕禮物》。我們來聽聽看。我只需要一樣東西，我不在乎禮物，我只需要聖誕樹，我不需要把襪子掛在壁爐上，聖誕老人不會用聖誕節的一件玩具讓我開心。
I just want you for my own More than you could ever know Make my wish come true All I want for Christmas is you I love that song. It is a great song. It's a great song. It always makes me think of the end of that movie, Love. Actually, I love that song. Well, it's also the most popular holiday ringtone. Oh. Okay, so for a very long time, Mariah Carey has had the number one spot on the Billboard Top 100 at the holidays.
我只想要你屬於我，遠超乎你的想像，讓我的願望成真，我聖誕節想要的只有你。我好喜歡這首歌。這真的是一首好歌。這是一首好歌。它總是讓我想起那部電影《愛是您·愛是我》的結尾。我太愛這首歌了。嗯，它也是最受歡迎的節日手機鈴聲。噢。所以很長一段時間以來，瑪麗亞·凱莉在節日時一直佔據告示牌百大單曲榜的第一名。
Like she has been the reigning queen. And the number two spot, year after year, would go to Brenda Lee for Rockin' Around the Christmas Tree. OK. You know that song? Yeah, of course. Well, all of that changed last year.
就像她一直都是當之無愧的女王。而第二名的位置，年復一年，則由布蘭達·李的《搖滾聖誕樹》奪得。好吧。你知道那首歌嗎？對，當然知道。嗯，去年一切都變了。
Last year? Last year was the 65th anniversary of Rockin' Around the Christmas Tree. And Brenda Lee decided she wanted number one. What'd she do? She went on talk shows, she shot a brand new music video for the song, she got her own TikTok account and started this whole
去年？去年是《搖滾聖誕樹》發行65週年。布蘭達·李決定她想要第一名。她做了什麼？她上了脫口秀節目，為這首歌拍攝了全新的音樂錄影帶，她開通了自己的抖音帳號，並開始了這整場
like campaign to make rockin' around the Christmas tree the number one song, finally. Like is there a TikTok dance and the whole thing? All, a big trend, yes. To give you a little context, Rockin' Around the Christmas Tree was originally recorded in 1958 when Brenda Lee was only 13 years old.
宣傳活動，最終讓《搖滾聖誕樹》成為第一名。就像有抖音舞蹈和那一整套東西嗎？對，這是一個巨大的潮流。為了讓你了解一下背景，《搖滾聖誕樹》最初錄製於1958年，當時布蘭達·李只有13歲。
Oh wow, she's been like at the top of the charts for so long. But never number one. Never. Well, guess what? Last year, she did it. No way. It worked. She dethroned Mariah Carey.
噢哇，她雄踞排行榜榜首這麼久了。但從來沒有拿過第一名。從來沒有。嗯，你猜怎麼著？去年，她做到了。不會吧。成功了。她把瑪麗亞·凱莉拉下了王座。
Her song hit number one on the Billboard's Top 100. It is the oldest song to hit number one. Brenda Lee became the oldest living person to score a number one song. And Rockin' Around the Christmas Tree is only the third holiday song to hit number one on the chart. What was the other one?
她的歌衝上了告示牌百大單曲榜的第一名。這是登上榜首歷史最悠久的歌曲。布蘭達·李成為獲得第一名歌曲的最年長在世人物。而且《搖滾聖誕樹》是排行榜上僅有的第三首登上第一名的聖誕歌曲。另外一首是什麼？
The third song is the Chipmunks song by the Chipmunks. These other two songs are such great songs. Could you imagine being Brenda Lee and being like, that song made it to number one before me? Anyway, Brenda Lee, you did it. I am so proud of you. I found an audio clip of her talking about what it's been like to have this Christmas song just enduring over the years and I want a dust to play it. Do you and your family listen to your song specifically during the holidays? Like surely it has to come on when you're out and about, when you're at the stores,
第三首歌是花栗鼠樂隊的歌曲。這另外兩首真的是太棒的歌了。你能想像成為布蘭達·李，然後心想，那首歌竟然在我之前就奪得第一名嗎？不管怎樣，布蘭達·李，你做到了。我為你感到自豪。我找到了一段她的音訊片段，談論這首聖誕歌多年來一直流傳至今的感受，我想放給大家聽聽。你和你的家人在節日期間會專門聽你的歌嗎？就像它肯定會在你們外出時、在商店裡播放，
but like do you guys listen to it? No. No? I mean if the kids put it on of course, but we don't make an effort to put me on. They hear enough of me every day. But no, I'm grateful that, you know, I don't think I'll ever get used to, during the Christmas season, walking into a big department store or something and hearing my song play. That's always going to be surreal to me.
但你們會聽嗎？不會。不會？我是說如果孩子們放的話當然會，但我們不會刻意播放我的歌。他們每天聽我的已經夠多了。但不會，我很感激，你知道，我想我永遠不會習慣在聖誕季走進一家大型百貨公司之類的商店時聽到我的歌在播放。對我來說這永遠都是超現實的。
Awww. How old was she when she finally was the number one Christmas song? 78. Wow. She recorded that when she was 13 number one Christmas song. 78. Wow. Mm-hmm. And she recorded that when she was 13. 13 years old. Should we hear it?
噢。她當上聖誕歌曲第一名時幾歲？78歲。哇。她13歲時就錄製了聖誕歌曲第一名。78歲。哇。嗯哼。而且她13歲時就錄製了那首歌。13歲。我們要聽聽看嗎？
Let's hear it. I think so. A little clip of it. Yes. Oh. Rockin' around the Christmas tree at the Christmas party hop Mistletoe home where you can see every couple tries to stop Rockin' around the Christmas tree, let the Christmas spirit ring
我們來聽聽看吧。我覺得可以。聽一小段。好。在聖誕派對舞會上搖滾聖誕樹，槲寄生下的家你可以看到每對情侶都試著停下來，搖滾聖誕樹，讓聖誕精神迴盪。
Later we'll have some pumpkin pie and we'll do some caroling. So good, right? Thirteen. Thirteen. Wow. Yeah. That's a great story. I loved that.
稍後我們吃點南瓜派，然後去唱聖誕頌歌。很棒對吧？13歲。13歲。哇。這真是一個棒極了的故事。我太喜歡了。
Well, Mariah Carey sent Brenda Lee flowers with a card when she was dethroned and it said this, dearest Miss Brenda, congratulations on your historic number one. Have a Merry Christmas. Love, Mariah. Classy. Classy. Yes. Well, that was our holiday bonus episode. Thanks to the nice folks at Macy's. We'll be sharing lots of fun stuff in our Insta stories from today's episode, so be sure and check them out. And a big thank you to Brian Baumgartner for stopping by the studio. We will share where you can get his book, The Night Before Dunder Mifflin, and he's going to be joining us again for our episode all about Kevin Malone. Please send in your questions. And next week we have another great
嗯，瑪麗亞·凱莉在布蘭達·李被拉下王座時送給她一束花和一張卡片，上面寫著：最親愛的布蘭達女士，祝賀你取得歷史性的第一名。聖誕快樂。愛你的，瑪麗亞。真有品味。真有品味。對。嗯，這就是我們的節日特別篇。感謝梅西百貨的好朋友們。我們將在今天的節目的限時動態中分享很多有趣的東西，所以一定要去看看。非常感謝布萊恩·鮑姆加特納來到工作室。我們會分享在哪裡可以買到他的書《鄧德米夫林的平安夜》，他接下來還會加入我們，一起聊聊關於凱文·馬隆的那集。請寄送你們的問題。下周我們還有另一集精彩的
episode. We are breaking down a fan favorite, which is the super fan hot girl episode. Yeah, you guys suggested that we break down one of the super fan episodes. So we rewatched hot girl. There were so many great new scenes and we found so much stuff. So join us next week for the hot girl super fan episode. We hope you have a great one. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fischer and Angela
節目。我們要剖析粉絲最愛的一集，也就是超級粉絲辣妹集。對，你們建議我們剖析其中一集超級粉絲版。所以我們重溫了《辣妹》。裡面有太多精彩的新鏡頭，我們發現了好多東西。所以請加入我們下週的辣妹超級粉絲集。我們祝你有個美好的一天。回頭見。感謝收聽「辦公室女士」。「辦公室女士」是Audyssey的節目，由珍娜·費雪和安琪拉·金西製作。
Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbico. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Berman and Leah Reese-Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. ["Ruppertree"]
我們的執行製作人是凱西·傑金斯。我們的音訊工程師是山姆·基弗，我們的副製作人是艾恩斯利·布比科。Audyssey的執行製作人是珍娜·韋斯-伯曼和莉婭·里斯-丹尼斯。「辦公室女士」由克里斯·巴西爾混音和母帶後製。我們的主題曲是克里·布拉頓的《魯珀特樹》。["魯珀特樹"]
Macy's is my best friend this holiday season. Angela, you're still my best friend, but Macy's is my best friend this holiday season. Angela, you're still my best friend, but Macy's is also my best friend because it is my one-stop shopping for gifting this season for everyone on my list. Macy's is taking care of me. OK. All right, I will allow it because Macy's gift guide
這個節日季梅西百貨是我最好的朋友。安琪拉，你依然是我最好的朋友，但這個節日季梅西百貨是我最好的朋友。安琪拉，你依然是我最好的朋友，但梅西百貨也是我最好的朋友，因為這是我這個節日季為我名單上的每個人採購禮物的一站式購物天堂。梅西百貨照顧到我了。好吧。好吧，我准許，因為梅西百貨的送禮指南
is the best. Here's the thing. Macy's gift guide really makes it easy. They have curated all of Macy's for guide is the best. Here's the thing, Macy's gift guide really makes it easy. They have curated all of Macy's for all things holiday. Well it's really convenient because you can search things by category. You can search things by price. Yeah, for example there's like a little thing like for the home. You click on that. It can show you different things you could buy for him, for her, click on that. It can show you different things you could buy for him, for her, and then the price range I do love. And you know, in my husband's family, we do a name draw. So do we. We do a gift exchange and sometimes you might get someone in your family and you really need
是最好的。事情是這樣的。梅西百貨的送禮指南真的讓事情變得很簡單。他們為節日的所有事物精心策劃了梅西百貨的所有指南是最好的。事情是這樣的，梅西百貨的送禮指南真的讓事情變得很簡單。他們為節日的所有事物精心策劃了梅西百貨的所有內容。嗯，這真的很方便，因為你可以按類別搜尋東西。你可以按價格搜尋。對，例如有一個小東西就像是家居用品。你點擊那個。它會向你展示你可以為他、為她買的不同東西，點擊那個。它會向你展示你可以為他、為她買的不同東西，然後價格區間我也很喜歡。而且你知道的，在我丈夫的家裡，我們會抽籤送禮物。我們也是。我們舉辦禮物交換，有時候你可能會抽到你家裡的某個人，而你真的很需要
some helpful ideas. I have spent so much time on the Macy's gift guide page this holiday season and it is really changing my life. Pick up items for everyone at Macy's this year. Shop macy's dot com slash gift guide for all things holiday to help you prepare for the season ahead. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
一些有幫助的想法。這個節日季我在梅西百貨送禮指南網頁上花了好久時間，它真的改變了我的生活。今年在梅西百貨為每個人挑選商品。造訪 macy's dot com slash gift guide 尋找與節日相關的所有事物，為即將到來的季節做好準備。本集還沒有評論。點擊文字記錄中的任何句子來發表評論。